welcome to the huberman lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine today my
guest is dr peter attia
dr t is a physician who's focused on
nutritional supplementation based
behavioral prescription drug and other
interventions that promote health span
and lifespan
his expertise spans from exercise
physiology to sleep physiology emotional
and mental health and pharmacology
today we talk about all those areas of
health starting with the very basics
such as how to evaluate one's own health
status and how to define one's health
trajectory we also talk about the
various sorts of interventions that one
can take in order to optimize vitality
while also extending longevity that is
lifespan dr atea is uniquely qualified
to focus on the complete depth and
breadth of topics that we cover and
indeed these are the same topics that he
works with his patients on in his clinic
every day dr atiya earned his bachelor
of science in mechanical engineering and
applied mathematics and his md from
stanford university school of medicine
he then went on to train at johns
hopkins hospital in general surgery one
of the premier hospitals in the world
where he was the recipient of several
prestigious awards including resident of
the year
he's been an author on comprehensive
reviews of general surgery he spent two
years at the national institutes of
health as a surgical oncology fellow at
the national cancer institute where his
work focused on immune-based therapies
for melanoma in the fields of science
and medicine it is well understood that
we are much the product of our mentors
and the mentoring we receive dr atia has
trained with some of the best and most
innovative lipidologists
endocrinologists gynecologists sleep
physiologists and longevity scientists
in the united states and canada so the
expertise that funnels through him and
that he shares with us today
is really harnessed from the best of the
best and his extensive training and
expertise by the end of today's episode
you will have answers to important basic
questions such as should you have blood
work how often should you do blood work
what specific things should you be
looking for on that blood work that are
either counterintuitive or not often
discussed and yet that immediately and
in the long term influence your lifespan
and health span we talk about hormone
health and hormone therapies for both
men and women we talk about drug
therapies that can influence the mind as
well as the body and of course we talk
about supplementation nutrition exercise
and predictors of lifespan and health
span it is an episode rich with
information
for some of you you may want to get out
a pen and paper in order to take notes
for others of you that learn better
simply by listening i just want to
remind you that we have time stamped all
this information so that you can go back
to the specific topics most of interest
to you i'm pleased to announce that the
hubermann lab podcast is now partnered
with momentous supplements we partnered
with momentous for several important
reasons first of all they ship
internationally because we know that
many of you are located outside of the
united states second of all and perhaps
most important the quality of their
supplements is second to none both in
terms of purity and precision of the
amounts of the ingredients
third we've really emphasized
supplements that are single ingredient
supplements and that are supplied in
dosages that allow you to build a
supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost that's
optimized for effectiveness and that you
can add things and remove things from
your protocol in a way that's really
systematic and scientific if you'd like
to see the supplements that we've
partnered with momentous on you can go
to livemomentus.com
huberman there you'll see those
supplements and just keep in mind that
we are constantly expanding the library
of supplements available through
momentous on a regular basis again
that's limentis.com
before we begin i'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme i'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is thesis thesis makes
custom nootropics that are designed for
your unique needs now to be honest i'm
not a fan of the word nootropics because
nootropics means smart drugs and to be
honest there is no such thing as a smart
drug because there's no neural circuit
for being smart there are neural
circuits rather for being creative or
for task switching or for focus and as
we all know different sorts of demands
whether or not they are cognitive or
physical require different types of
cognitive and physical abilities thesis
understands this and has created a kit
of custom nootropics that are tailored
to your needs to get your own
personalized nootropic starter kit you
can go to takethesis.com huberman take
their three-minute quiz and thesis will
send you four different formulas to try
in your first month that's take thesis
dot com slash hubermann and use the code
huber minute checkout to get 10 off your
first box of custom nootropics today's
episode is also brought to us by inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and dna to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals
i've long been a believer in getting
regular blood work done for the simple
reason that many of the factors that
impact your immediate and long-term
health can only be assessed from a
quality blood test and nowadays with the
advent of modern dna tests you can also
analyze for instance what your
biological age is and compare it to your
chronological age and obviously it's
your biological age that really matters
the challenge with a lot of blood tests
and dna tests however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
hormones and so forth but you don't know
what to do with that information inside
tracker makes it very easy to know what
to do with that information to optimize
your health they have a personalized
platform it's a dashboard that you go to
you can click on the level of any
hormone metabolic factor lipid etc and
it will tell you the various sorts of
interventions based on nutrition
supplementation etc that you can use to
bring those numbers into the ranges that
are ideal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans that's insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off today's episode
is also brought to us by helix sleep
helix sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are of the absolute highest quality
they also have some really unique
features because they are customized to
your unique sleep needs i've talked over
and over again on this podcast and on
another podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance there's
just simply no other substitute for a
quality night sleep on a regular basis
i've been sleeping on a helix mattress
for well over a year now and it's the
best sleep that i've ever had and that's
in large part because the mattress was
designed for me
what you need to know however is what's
the ideal mattress for you and you can
do that by going to helix site you can
take their brief quiz which will ask you
do you sleep on your side your back your
stomach or maybe you don't know or maybe
all three do you tend to run hot or cold
in the night maybe you know maybe you
don't
at the end of that short quiz they will
match you to the ideal mattress for you
i match to the dusk the dusk mattress
but again that's what i need that's not
certainly what you need in order to get
your best night's sleep but if you're
interested in upgrading your mattress go
to helix sleep.com huberman take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress for you and
you'll get up to 200 off any mattress
order and two free pillows they have
terrific pillows and you get to try out
that mattress for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but i'm certain
you will again if you're interested you
go to helixsleep.com huberman for up to
200 off your mattress order and two free
pillows and now for my discussion with
dr peter atia peter thanks for joining
me today thanks for having me man i've
been looking forward to this for a very
long time that's why i'm a huge fan of
your podcast
i know that you went to stanford and
worked with a number of people that are
colleagues of mine so for me this is
already a thrill just just to be doing
this yeah well
likewise i have a ton of questions uh
but i want to start off with something
that i wonder a lot about and that i
know
many
other people wonder about which is
how to assess their current health and
their trajectory
in terms of health and well-being
specifically as it relates to blood work
so what are your thoughts on blood work
is it necessary
for the typical person so this is
somebody who's not dealing with some
acute syndrome or illness
and
at what age would you suggest people
start getting blood work how frequently
should they get blood work how often do
you get blood work done etc
yeah there's a lot there i mean the way
i talk about this with patients is
first taking everything back to the
objective so what what what's the what's
the
what's the thing we're trying to
optimize so
if if a person says look i'm i'm trying
to break 10 hours for an iron man
i don't know that blood work is going to
be a game-changing aspect of their
trajectory and their training you know
they're going to benefit much more from
sort of functional analyses of
performance
so i'm assuming based on the question
that you're really coming at this
through the lens of living longer and
living better through the lifespan
health span
mostly yeah and just i think most people
have some sense of their vitality or
lack of vitality but i think everyone
wonders whether or not they could feel
better and whether or not blood work
will give them a window into how they
might go about feeling better
yeah i think it does to some extent but
i also think that it has a lot of blind
spots so i kind of
you know break things down into the two
vectors that make up longevity which are
lifespan and health span
so lifespan is the easiest of those
vectors to understand because it's it's
pretty binary you're alive or you're not
alive you're respiring or you're not you
make atp or you don't end of story
so
um what gets in the way of lifespan
is essentially the four horsemen of
disease right so atherosclerotic disease
cancer neurodegenerative disease and
metabolic disease which directly isn't
the cause of many deaths but you know
basically creates the foundation to all
of those other diseases
um
so you know if you're a non-smoker what
i just rattled off is about 80 of your
death
so
how does blood work help address those
it varies so on the atherosclerotic
standpoint it's a very good predictor of
risk if you know what to look for
so primarily apob would be the single
most important um lipoprotein that we
care about i can explain what that means
in a second
and then also you know other markers of
inflammation endothelial health
and metabolic health
when it comes to cancer you know blood
testing in the sense of biomarkers is
not particularly helpful outside of
knowing that the second leading
environmental or modifiable cause of
cancer is metabolic ill health after
smoking so
we don't actually know a lot about
cancer in the sense of what causes it
it's really stochastic and it's a lot of
bad luck
so we know that smoking drives it and we
know that
even though
epidemiologically we say obesity drives
it what it really means is metabolic
poor health it's probably the
hyperinsulinemia that comes with obesity
that drives it
so biomarkers help with that but there's
still an enormous blind spot to cancer
we could talk about liquid biopsies
aside because those aren't really
biomarker studies but put that away
on the neurodegenerative side you know i
don't think we have a lot of insight
that comes to understanding parkinson's
disease
but when it comes to dementia
particularly alzheimer's disease which
is the most prevalent form of dementia i
think the biomarkers can be quite
helpful
they overlap a lot with the
atherosclerotic diseases so
the same things that you know drive the
risk of heart disease are drawing
driving the risk of dementia
and then there's some novel stuff as
well if you include genetic testing
which you can get out of a blood test we
get a whole suite of genes not just apoe
but far more you know nuanced stuff than
that that can also play a role so you
can stratify risk in that sense so in
aggregate i would say
you know blood testing of biomarkers
provides pretty good insight into
lifespan
when you get into health span you have
kind of the cognitive physical emotional
domains
i think here the the biomarkers are far
less helpful and here we kind of rely
more on
functional testing so when it comes to
sort of the cognitive piece you know you
can do cognitive testing
in terms of long-term risk a lot of the
things that imply good cognitive
health as you age
are in line with the same things that
you would do to reduce the risk of
dementia
so all the biomarkers that you would
look to improve through dementia risk
reduction you would be improving through
cognitive health
on the physical side i mean outside of
looking at hormone levels and things
which we look at extensively and
understanding how those might
aid in or prevent some of the metrics
that matter
it really is
this is a biomarker a side thing i mean
i'd be much more interested in a
person's dexa c-pet testing vo2 max
testing you know
zone two lactate testing fat oxidation
those what i consider more functional
tests that give me far more insight into
that and then of course the emotional
piece which depending on you know who
you are might be the single most
important piece without which none of
this other stuff matters right if you're
a totally miserable human being your
relationships suck
i don't think any of this other stuff
matters and certainly there's nothing
that i'm looking at in biomarkers it's
giving me great insight into that
do you ask about emotional state or do
you try and assess emotional state
indirectly when you do an intake with
one of your patients
um probably not so much in the intake
because i think it takes a while to form
a relationship with a patient before
that starts to become
something that they're necessarily going
to want to talk with you about but i
definitely think of it as an important
part of what we do
and
i think without it none of this other
stuff really matters again the irony
of thinking about how many years i spent
sort of in pursuit of
fully optimizing every detail of
everything without any attention being
paid to that dimension is not lost on me
and look there are some patients who
they that's just not something that
that's something that's
compartmentalized maybe they're you know
they're doing well in that department or
maybe they aren't but they just aren't
willing to engage on that yet
in terms of frequency of blood testing
if somebody feels pretty good
and is taking a number of steps exercise
nutrition etc to try and
extend lifespan and improve health span
is once a year frequent enough um and
should a 20 year old start getting blood
work done just to get a window into
what's going on assuming that they can
afford it or their insurance can cover
it yeah i mean look i i certainly think
everybody should be screened early in
life because if you look at like what's
the single most prevalent genetic driver
of atherosclerosis is lp little a
so unfortunately most physicians don't
know what lp little a is and yet you
know somewhere between eight and twelve
percent of the population has a high
enough and depending on who you you know
uh i had a recent guest on my podcast
who suggested it could be as high as 20
have a high enough lp little a that it
is contributing to atherosclerosis so to
not want to know that when it's
genetically determined right this is
something that you know you're you're
born with this and you only need to
really check it once why we wouldn't
want to know that in a 20 year old when
it can contribute to a lot of the early
atherosclerosis we see in people uh you
know it just it's you know it's leaving
money on the table in my opinion the
frequency with which you need to test
really comes down to
the
state of interventions you know i i
don't think it makes sense to just do
blood tests for the sake of doing blood
tests there has to be kind of a reason
is something changing um you know a
blood test is for the most part a static
intervention uh it's a it's a it's a
it's a look at a window in time
and
there's benefit in having you know a few
of those over the course of a year
if you're unsure about a level so if
something comes back and it doesn't look
great yeah it might make sense just to
recheck it without reacting to it but
typically you know in patients we might
check blood two to four times a year but
we're also probably doing things in
there to to now check like hey you know
we we gave this drug that it had the
desired outcome um you know you put on
three pounds of muscle and lost three
pounds of fat did it have the desired
outcome
um
speaking of tracking weight and um
fat lean mass percentages is that
something that you recommend your
patients do pretty often i know people
that step on the scale every day i know
people like myself that frankly i might
step on the scale three times a year i
don't really care i care i pay attention
to other things that are far more
subjective
maybe i'm making a huge mistake what are
your thoughts about
um quantitative measurements of
weight uh bmi
uh for the typical person
i think they're pretty crude um i think
a dexa i'd rather take a dexa annually
and then maybe follow weight a little
bit more closely to get a sense of it
and so with adexa you're getting
at least the way we look at the data
four pieces of information now most
people when they do a dexa
should i explain what that is yeah i
think some people might not know what
dex is i in fact i confess i have a
crude understanding of what it is um my
tell me of where i'm wrong and um
hopefully where i'm par at least
partially right my understanding is that
there are a number of different ways to
measure lean mass to non-lean mass ratio
and there's one where they put you under
water there's one where they put you
into some sort of non-underwater chamber
there's calipering yep and then there's
the um looking in the mirror and um
pinching and uh changing the lighting
you know it's funny when you if you've
if you've done it enough you can i can
sort of tell my body fat by my abs
right so i can sort of tell by you know
how good the six-pack or how bad the
six-pack is what the leanness is and
that's that's actually not a terrible uh
way to do it there you know bodybuilder
for example which i've never been can
can tell you the difference between
being six percent seven percent eight
percent ten percent just based on the
degree of visibility within within the
abs um but
basically a dexa scan is an x-ray
um so it's the same principle as you
know just getting a chest x-ray where
ionizing radiation is passed through the
body and there's a plate behind the body
that collects what comes through and
they're the denser
the medium that the electrons are trying
to go through uh the less of them that
are collected so when you look at an
x-ray as everybody's probably seen an
x-ray that which is white is most dense
so if you had you know a piece of metal
in your pocket it would show up as a
bright white thing that's why ribs and
bones show up as white
and the things that are the least dense
like the lungs where it's just air are
the blackest
and everything is a shade of gray in
between
so adexa is just doing that effectively
but it's a moving x-ray so you lay down
on a bed and it takes maybe 10 minutes
and this little
very low power x-ray kind of goes over
your body
and the plate beneath it is is
collecting information that is basically
allowing it to differentiate between
three things
bone mineral content
fat
other
and the other is quantified as lean body
mass so that's organs muscles everything
else
so when most people do a dexa the for
you know they get the report back and
the reports are horrible i've yet to see
one company that can do this in a way
that isn't abjectly horrible we've
created our own templates so we have our
own dashboard for how we do this because
we've just given up on trying to use
theirs
but the first thing most people look at
is what's my body fat
and this is the gold standard outside of
like mri or something that's only used
for research purposes so so adexa is
going to produce a far better estimate
of body fat than calipers
or
buoyancy testing or things like that
provided the machinery is well
calibrated and the operator knows how to
use it
i've heard some people argue that in the
hands of
like
the guy who's been doing calipers his
whole life
it could probably be comparable with
calipers but
nevertheless for an off-the-shelf tech
you know dex is amazing
you know of the four things that get
spit out of the dexa we think that the
body fat is the least interesting and so
i would rank that as fourth on the list
of what's germaine to your health the
other three things that you get spit out
are bone mineral density
visceral fat
and then the metrics that allow you to
compute like to basically compute what's
called appendicular lean mass index and
fat free mass index and so those three
metrics are significantly more important
than body fat
and um the reason is as follows right so
so bone mineral density
basically speaks to your risk of
osteoporosis um
and osteopenia um and that doesn't sound
very sexy to people our age you know 50
year old guy is listening to this it's
like yeah big deal but for a 50 year old
woman this is a huge deal right a woman
who's just about to go through menopause
or has just gone through menopause is at
an enormous risk for osteopenia and and
then ultimately osteoporosis because
estrogen is
the single most important hormone in
regulating bone mineral density
and we can come back and talk about why
that's the case but it's it's very
interesting how the how the biomechanics
of of
bones work and why estrogen specifically
is so important
and this is a huge cause of morbidity
right so you know if you're over the age
of 65 and you fall and break your hip
your one year morbidity is about 30 to
40 percent
which again just to put that in english
if you're 65 or older you fall and break
your hip there's a 30 to 40 chance
you're dead in a year
wow
bones matter
um
so we want to really get a sense of
where you stack up for your age for your
sex and if you're anywhere off the pace
we have to ramp up our strategy and be
super aggressive about how to increase
that or at a minimum
prevent any further decay and are there
age-related charts for these sorts of
things yeah this is this all gets spit
out into what's called a z-score so when
you're looking at your bmd it's going to
give you a z-score so a z-score of zero
means uh and you understand this but
it's like it's resist we're referring to
a probability distribution in a standard
mode so z-score of zero means you're at
the 50th percentile for your age and sex
a z-score of plus one you're one
standard deviation above minus one below
et cetera um there's also a t-score
which is doing the same thing but
comparing you to a young person and so
the t-score is technically used to make
the diagnosis of osteopenia osteoporosis
we tend to look more at the z-score and
basically say look if your z-score right
now is minus one
in four years i want your z-score to be
zero not necessarily because you've
increased that entire way but maybe
you've increased slightly while it's
expected that you would have declined
i see
what are some things that we can do to
improve bone mineral density at any age
so it turns out there's a real critical
window in which we are malleable so
depending on the age at which someone's
listening to us discuss this
um you know if you're if you're under
2025
you are still in that time of your life
when you are able to reach your
potential
so
um it turns out that strength training
is probably the single best thing you
can do
and this was a surprise to me because we
you know we did an ama on this topic a
little while ago and that's when i got
you know really deep on this with our
analysts
my assumption was running must be the
best like some sort of impact must be
the best thing you can do it was you
know i assumed running would be better
than swimming and cycling but it turned
out that power lifting was probably the
best thing you could do um and i think
once you understand how bones work it
became more clear which is you know
power lifting is really putting more of
a sheer force from the muscle via the
tendon onto the bone
and that's what the bones are really
sensing they're sensing that sheer force
that's being applied through the bone in
a compressive way depending on the bone
of course and that's what's basically
activating the osteoblasts which are the
cells that are you know
allowing bone to be
built
so
it's this is this turns out to be
probably more important for females
um
because
how high you can get during that period
of development say until you're 20 or 25
basically sets your trajectory for the
rest of your life so where we get into
real trouble is with patients who for
example
used large amounts of inhaled steroids
during that period of their life because
let's say they had really bad asthma
or patients who needed large amounts of
corticosteroids for some other immune
related condition so during their
critical window of development they were
taking a drug that was impairing this
process
so you know we have some patients like
that in our practice and that's you know
just an enormous liability that we're
working really hard to overcome you know
with nutrition with hormones with drugs
with training um
and you know it's it you know it's just
something you have to be aware of i
wasn't aware that um
inhalants for asthma and things of that
sort can impair bone mineral density
yeah they're steroid-based
some of them of course are just beta
agonists and they're fine so anything
corticosterone like yup interesting and
then i always get asked this question
and
i always reflexively want to say no but
i don't really know the answer so i
don't reply what about topical um
corticosterone you know people will put
cortisone cream to me it seems almost
inconceivable that it would have a
systemic effect but then again what do i
know it's all it's all dose and it's all
docent and time related so you know if
you're talking about like i've got a
little rash under my skin i'm going to
put you know corticosteroids on probably
not
um but but certainly with enough of it
put on i mean it is absorbed so
it could be an issue but that's not
typically what we're concerned with i
mean we're mostly concerned with people
that are
you know taking even modest amounts of
prednisone for months years at a time
um or like i said kids that are using
steroid inhalers
for
years and years and years again i'm not
suggesting that if your kids on a
steroid inhaler they shouldn't be you
have to solve the most important problem
and if asthma is the most important
problem so be it i think you just want
to turn that into okay well how much
more
imperative is it that our kid is doing
things that are putting a high amount of
stress on their bones and via their
muscles to make sure that they're in
that maximal capacity to build
do you think that somebody in their 30s
or 40s or 50s could still benefit from
strength training in terms of bone
mineral density and longevity um as it
relates to bone mineral density um given
that there's this
key window earlier they might have
missed that oh yeah no no this is
essential for the rest of life because
you're now trying to prevent the fall
off so so basically the way it works is
you you're sort of from from birth to
say 20 you're on you're in growth
from 20 to 50 you plateau
at 50 men start to decline but it's
really small women start to decline and
it's precipitous and it's related to the
drop in estrogen associated with
menopause or pre-menopausal correct and
and can we get into any of the
broad uh contours of what that straight
training looks like we had a dr andy
galpin on the show he talked a lot about
ways to build strength versus
hypertrophy versus endurance etc i think
there's pretty good agreement across the
fields of you know
physiotherapy etc physiology and
medicine in terms of how to do that but
my understanding is
fairly low repetition ranges so this is
anywhere from one to six repetitions
typically
not aiming for you know a pump
hypertrophy that sort of thing but heavy
loads that are hard to move 80 percent
of one repetition maximum or more done
with long rest periods um
three two to you know three times a week
type thing is that about right yeah if
you if you look at the literature on
this it's gonna tell you it's gonna
differentiate powerlifting from
weightlifting
in other words yeah you do need to be
kind of moving against a very heavy load
now again that can look very different
depending on your level of experience
like i really like dead lifting now i
mean i can count the number of days left
in my life when i'm going to want to do
sets over 400 pounds but
you know i'll pick and choose the days
that i do but but you know i grew up
doing those things i'm comfortable with
those movements if i had a 60 year old
woman who's never lifted weights in her
life who we now have to get lifting
i mean we could get her to deadlift but
i i think i wouldn't make you know
perfect the enemy of good i'd be happy
to put her on a leg press machine and
just get her doing that
um
you know it's not as pure a movement as
a deadlift but who cares right we can
still put her at a heavy load
for her and do so safely so um
now that said i mean there was a study
that was done in australia and i'm you
know hopefully we can find a link to it
it's there's a video on youtube that
actually kind of has the pi sort of
walking through the results i could send
it to you okay yeah and it's it's just
amazing they took a group of you know
older women they look like they're in
their 60s or 70s who had never lifted
weights in their life who you know had
osteopenia and some probably already had
osteoporosis and they basically just put
them on a strength training protocol and
it is remarkable to watch these women
they're doing good mornings they're
doing deadlifts they're picking heavy
things up off the ground i think one
woman was picking up
god i want to say she was like
picking like 50 60 kilos up off the
ground i mean just staggering sums of
weight for these women who have never
done anything
and
their bone health is improving
at this age so
um
the goal frankly is to just you know
never get to the point where
you know you have to do this for the
first time
you know strength training is such an
essential part of our existence
that um
you know there's never it's never too
late to start but you should never stop
i love that advice is it a systemic
effect or a local effect so for instance
um let's say that well my mother's in
her late 70s um she actually used to be
really strong when we were kids she
could move this fish tank that was in my
room long before i could move it and um
she's really strong over the years um i
would i wouldn't call her frail by any
means but i certainly think she could
benefit from some strength training
let's say she were to start doing some
leg presses or start even with air
squats and maybe work up to some
push-ups
are the effects all local meaning if she
were to just train her legs or just do
push-ups um would it only be the loads
applied to the
limbs and muscles and tissues i think
that's where the bulk of it is yeah okay
yeah so you need to train the whole body
essentially yeah now keep in mind the
diagnosis of osteopenia and osteoporosis
is based on only three locations the
left hip the right hip and the lumbar
spine
so
um
you know that's just the convention by
which we make the diagnosis
and and i think part of that has to do
with that's where the majority of the
insults occur now not all of the insults
i've seen people that have you know
because of horrible bone density they're
they're you know they're fracturing
ankles and tibia fibula like they're
having low tib fib fractures just
walking
so clearly bone density outside of those
regions does matter but much of it is
really focused on and by the way you
know you fall you break a wrist so so
this is a systemic issue um but the
majority of the response is a local
response because it really comes down to
putting a load directly on that bone and
then having that bone in kind respond by
laying down more bone
before we continue with today's
discussion i'd like to just briefly
acknowledge our sponsor athletic greens
now called ag-1
athletic greens akag-1 is an all-in-one
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that
also has adaptogens and digestive
enzymes i've been taking athletic greens
since way back in 2012 so i'm delighted
that they're sponsoring the podcast the
reason i started taking athletic greens
and the reason i still drink athletic
greens twice a day is that it supplies
total foundational coverage of my
vitamin mineral needs and it supplies
important nutrients that i need to
support my gut microbiome the gut
microbiome as many of you know supports
the immune system it also supports the
so-called gut brain axis which is vital
for mood for energy levels regulating
focus and many other features of our
mental health and physical health that
impact our daily performance and high
performance in any endeavors we might be
involved in if you'd like to try
athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com
huberman and claim a special offer
they're giving away five free travel
packs plus a year's supply of vitamin d3
k2 with every order and of course
vitamin d3 k2 are vital for all sorts of
things like hormone health and metabolic
health and k2 for cardiovascular health
and calcium regulation again you can go
to athleticgreens.com huberman to claim
that special offer you mentioned falling
and the problems with falling and
breaking things and mortality related to
that
i wonder whether or not there are also
um health related effects of just having
weak bones that are not just about
falling and breaking a bone and
dying a year later even though that's
obviously very severe um because i think
when people hear about that some people
might think well i'll just be more
careful i'll just move more slowly i'll
sit in a wheelchair if i need to if um
even though i might be able to walk if
it keeps me from falling some people i
think adopt that mentality
what are some of the benefits of having
high bone mineral density for men and
women that are perhaps independent of
risk of injury well i think it's
actually the inverse of what you just
said right it's sort of like
you have to sort of
be able to articulate what it is you
want in your marginal decade so we use
this thing in our practice called the
marginal decade marginal decade is the
last decade of your life so everyone
will have a marginal decade that's the
only thing i can tell you with absolute
certainty
right i believe you there's no
immortality there's no hidden elixir
that's going to help us live to be you
know whatever i mean we're all going to
be in our last decade at some point
and outside of people who die suddenly
or through an accident
most of us know when we're in that
marginal decade you might not know the
day you enter it but most people
you know who are old enough if you tell
them are you in the last decade of your
life they probably have a sense that
they are
so i think the exercise that we like to
go through with our patients very early
on
is
have them
in exquisite detail more detail than
they've ever considered so we have to
prompt them with like 50 questions
um lay out what their marginal decade
should look like
wow
that's a serious exercise it's a very
serious exercise right like what tell me
everything that is going to happen in
your marginal decade i don't know when
it's going to be andrew it could be 87
to 97 if we're doing well right it might
be 79 to 89 i don't know but i i you
know it would really be in a very
nuanced exploration of that topic
and i think until you do that all of
this other stuff is just
abstract
and kind of nonsense
you know until a person can tell you
what it is that they want to be doing in
that last decade
you can't design a program to get them
there i mean think about it you know
someone wants to do an ironman we take
it for granted that we know what the
objective is i have to be able to swim
two and a half miles i have to be able
to get out take my wetsuit off hop on my
bike ride 112 miles get off my bike take
the bike shoes off put the run shoes on
run 26.2 miles like we get it we know
what the objective is and only by
knowing that can you train can you
imagine if i said to you andrew i'm
going to have you do an athletic event
in a year start training
i'm not going to tell you what it is
right just do it right it could be
playing basketball
you know it could be swimming to
catalina island it could be running 100
miles you wouldn't be able to do it so
similarly if we don't know what our
marginal decade is meant to be
there's no way to train for it
do you think this is a good exercise for
anyone and everyone to do on their own
regardless of age here i'm hearing this
and i'm thinking i need to think about
when my last decade might be and what i
want that to look like
absolutely i mean when i say we do with
our patients that's only because that's
the population i work with but there's
simply no reason everybody shouldn't be
going through this exercise and then you
you sort of back script from there
out what people should be doing given
their current health status exactly
right we call it back casting so the
first step we do is once we've really
delineated what the objective function
looks like
we then say okay how do you break down
that into
uh metrics that we can measure
so you know you describe doing a whole
bunch of things okay just to let you
know to do that will require a vo2 max
of 30 milliliters of oxygen per minute
per kilogram
and the person will say okay what does
that mean
we'll say well that's a measure of your
maximal uptake of oxygen
and that declines at about eight percent
to ten percent per decade
so if you have to be at 30 and let's
just assume you're going to be doing
that at 90. so what do you need to be at
80 70 60 50. okay here's what it would
need to be at 50. okay what are you now
ah there's a big gap you're below where
you need to be now so you're obviously
higher than 30 now
but if you're only at 42 now and you
need to be at 30 and 40 years
you're not going to cut it you have to
be a lot fitter okay now let's do the
same exercise around strength and
stability and without exception most
people when they do this exercise will
find out they're well below where they
need to be so the gravity of aging is
more vicious than people realize and
therefore the height of your glider
needs to be much higher than you think
it is when you're our age if you want to
be able to do the things we probably
won't be able to do when we're 90. i
absolutely love this approach i've never
done it in terms of my health i've
always thought about what i want to
accomplish in the next three to six
months or next year or so and by the way
that's a great approach that's
forecasting forecasting is fantastic
forecasting is really good at short-term
things it doesn't work for long-term
things long-term you have to do
back-casting
this back-casting approach really
appeals to me because in my career well
i never anticipate excuse me i never
anticipated i'd be podcasting um
but that that's why i did at some point
as an undergraduate i look professors
and that looks like a pretty good life
they seem pretty happy i talked to a few
of them and then i figured out what i
need to do at each stage in order to get
to that next rung on the ladder and just
kind of figured it out in uh in a bad
casting kind of way as you refer to it
i think it's incredibly useful because
it puts all the questions about blood
work and how often they get blood work
and what to measure in in a really nice
context that's a highly individualized
i've never heard of this before so um
and i should give a nod to annie duke i
used to always refer to this as reverse
engineering but in annie duke's book she
wrote about this exact thing and called
it back casting and i was like i like
the term backcasting better it i think
it's more intuitive than reverse
engineering yeah there's a real genius
to it and i think it because it sets so
many things into the appropriate bins
and trajectories
i've heard you talked before about some
of the prime movers for longevity and
all risk mortality
and i'd love for you to review a little
bit of that for us um i think we all
know that we shouldn't smoke because
it's very likely that we'll die earlier
if we smoke nicotine uh i'm neither a
marijuana nor a nicotine smoker so i
feel on stable ground there but anytime
we see smoking nowadays people won't
really want to distinguish between
cannabis and nicotine
so i am curious about any differences
there in terms of
impact on longevity
but in that context what are the things
that anyone and everyone can do should
do
to to live longer basically
how long you got
well you tell me
you tell me um i'd like to live to be
i'd like my final decade to be between
90 and 100. oh no i meant how long do
you think yeah
and will we spend from now until you're
90. well there's a risk of that but um
top contour is fine i know you've done a
lot of content on this and we'll we will
give people links to some of that more
in-depth content but
you know let's say we're on a short
flight from here to san diego uh we're
in los angeles now um and we've got
takeoff and landing and we don't want to
kink our neck too much by doing this
thing so if i just said hey you know
give me the the
extended version of the three by five
card uh yeah what does that look like um
so let's start with a couple of the
things that you've already highlighted
so smoking how much does smoking
increase your risk of all-cause
mortality and the reason we like to talk
about what's called acm or all-cause
mortality is it's really agnostic to how
you die
and that doesn't always make sense i
mean if you're talking about you know a
very specific intervention like a
anti-cancer therapeutic you really care
about cancer-specific mortality or
heart-specific mortality but when we
talk about these sort of broad things we
like to talk about acm so you know using
smoking smoking is approximately a 40
increase in the risk of acm
what does that translate to and um that
means i'm
i'm shortening my life by 40 no it means
at any point in time there's a 40
percent great greater risk that you're
going to die relative to a non-smoker
and a never smoker yeah yeah so it's
important to distinguish it doesn't mean
your lifespan is going to be 40 less it
means at any point in time standing
there your risk of death is 40 higher
um and by the way that'll catch up with
you right at some point that that
catches up um high blood pressure it's
about a 20 to 25 increase in all-cause
mortality um you take something really
extreme like end-stage kidney disease so
these are patients that are on dialysis
waiting for an organ and again there's a
confounder there because there's what's
the underlying condition that leads you
to that it's you know profound
hypertension you know significant type 2
diabetes that's been uncontrolled you
know that's enormous that's about 170
increase in acm so the hazard ratio is
like 2.75
um type 2 diabetes is probably about a
1.25
as well so 25 increase so now the
question is like how do you improve so
what are the things that improve those
so now here we do this by comparing
low to high achievers and other metrics
so if you look at
low muscle mass versus high muscle mass
what is the
and it's pretty significant it's about
3x so if you compare low muscle mass
people to high muscle mass people as
they age the low muscle mass people have
about a 3x hazard ratio or 200 percent
increase in all-cause mortality
now if you look at the data more
carefully you realize that it's probably
less the muscle mass fully
doing that and it's more the high
association with strength and when you
start to
tease out
strength you can realize that strength
could be probably three and a half x as
a hazard ratio meaning about 250 percent
greater risk
if you have low strength to high
strength
my strength is the ability to move loads
at 80 to 90.
it's all defined by given studies so
some the most common things that are
used are actually
you know they're used for the purposes
of experiments that make it easy to do i
don't even think they're the best
metrics so they're usually using like
grip strength um
leg extensions
and like wall sits squats things like
that okay so how long can you sit in a
squatted position at 90 degrees without
support would be a great demonstration
of quad strength a leg extension um you
know how much weight can you hold for
how long relative to body weight things
like that
you know we we have a whole strength
program that we do with our patients we
have something called the sma so it's
the strength metrics assessment and we
put them through 11
tests that um are really difficult you
know like a dead hang is one of them
like how long can you dead hang your
body weight stuff like that so
we're trying to be more granular in that
insight but tie it back to these
principles
if you look at cardiorespiratory fitness
it's even more profound
so
if you look at people who are in the
bottom 25 for their age and sex in terms
of vo2 max and you compare them to the
people that are just at the 50th to 75th
percentile um you're talking about a 2x
difference roughly in
in in the risk of acm if you compare the
bottom 25
to the top 2.5 percent so you're talking
about you know bottom quarter to the
elite for a given age um you're talking
about 5x wow 400
difference in all-cause mortality that's
probably the single strongest
association i've seen for any modifiable
behavior
incredible so when you say elite these
are people that are running marathons at
a pretty rapid clip not necessarily it's
just like what the vo2 max is for that
like my vo2 max would be in the elite
for my age group
uh my vo2 max you know but again it's
i'm training very deliberately to make
sure that it's in that so i wouldn't
consider myself elite at anything
anymore but i still maintain a vo2 max
that is elite for my age i consider you
an elite physician and podcast
end guy all around but true um
but in terms of
okay so but the point is like you don't
have to be a world-class athlete to be
elite here yeah got it um
so maybe we could talk a little bit
about the specifics around the training
to get into that um you know top two
tiers there because it seems that those
are enormous positive effects of
cardiovascular exercise uh far greater
than the sorts of numbers that i see
around
let's just say supplement a or something
and that's you know like this is my
whole pet peeve in life right it's like
i just can't get enough of the
machinating and arguing about this
supplement versus that supplement
and
i feel like you shouldn't be having
those arguments until you have your
exercise house in order um you know you
shouldn't be arguing about your
this nuance of your carnivore diet
versus this nuance of your paleo diet
versus this nuance of your vegan diet
like
until you can deadlift your body weight
for 10 reps like then then you can come
and talk about those things or something
like let's just start with some metrics
like until your vo2 max is at least to
the 75th percentile and you're able to
dead hang for at least a minute and
you're able to wall sit for at least two
like we could rattle off a bunch of
relatively low hanging fruit
i wish there was a rule that said like
you couldn't talk about anything else
health related like you just we can make
that rule no one will listen to it i
don't know about that we can make
whatever rules we want we can call it
atiya's rule one thing i've done before
in this podcast on social media is just
borrowing from the tradition in science
which is it's inappropriate to name
something after yourself unless you were
a scientist before 1950 um but it's
totally appropriate to name things after
other people so i'm going to call it a
tia's rule until you can do the
following things um don't talk about
please refrain from talking about
supplements and nutrition here it is
hereafter
thought of referred to and referenced as
a tia's rule i coined the phrase not him
so there's no ego involved but it is now
atiya's rule watch out hashtag atiya's
rule oh god um wikipedia entry atiyah's
rule in all seriousness and i am serious
about that um dead hang for about a
minute seems like a really good goal for
a lot of people at least that's our
that's our goal i think we have a minute
and a half is the goal for a 40 year old
woman two minutes is the goal for 40
year old man so we adjust them up and
down based on uh age and gender great
and then uh the wall set what's what are
some we don't use a wall sit we do as
just a straight squat air squat at 90
degrees
and i believe two minutes is the
standard for both men and women at 40.
great and then uh because for some
people thinking in terms of vo2 max is a
little more complicated they might not
have access to the equipment or the to
measure it etc um
what can we talk about think about in
terms of cardiovascular so run a mile at
uh seven minutes or last eight minutes
that's a good question so there are vo2
there are really good vo2 max estimators
online and you can plug in your activity
du jour so it would be at a bike run or
rowing machine and it can give you a
sense of that and i i don't remem i used
to know all of those okay but now that i
just actually do the testing i don't
recall them but it's exactly that line
of thinking like can you run a mile in
this time if you can your vo2 max is
approximately this great and and i think
somewhere in my podcast realm i've got
all those charge charts posted of like
this is by age
by sex this is what the vo2 max is in
each of those buckets terrific we'll
provide links just to those we'll have
our people find those links and then um
you mentioned dead lifting body weight
10 times i just made that one up no
that's not one that we include but but
something something like that um we use
we use farmer carries so we'll say for a
male you should be able to farm or carry
your body weight for i think we have two
minutes
so that's half your body weight in each
hand um you'd be able to walk with that
for for two minutes um for women i think
we're doing 75 percent of body weight or
something like that yeah great i i love
it um as indirect measures of how
healthy and yeah huge we are and how
long we're going to live it's basically
grip strength it's mobility i mean again
walking with that much weight for for
some people initially is really hard um
you know we use different things like
vertical jump ground contact time if
you're jumping off a box things like
that so it's it's really trying to
capture and it's an evolution right like
i think the the test is going to get
only more and more involved as we as we
as we get involved because it took us
about a year
beth lewis did the majority of the work
to develop this um beth runs our
strength and stability program in the
practice and you know basically i just
tasked her with like hey go out to the
literature and come up with
all of the best movements that we think
are proxies for what you need to
be like the most kick-ass you know what
we call centenary into catholic which is
the person living in their marginal
decade at the best
well what i'm about to say is certainly
a mechanistic leap but if you look at
the literature on
exercise-related neurogenesis in mice
or brain atrophy or brain hypertrophy
etc
in animal models it's very clear that
the best way to get a nervous system to
atrophy to lose neurons shrink
neurons and or lose connections between
neurons is to stop that animal from
moving
or to de-enrich its environment to
deprive it of some sensory input or
multiple sensory inputs and the best way
to enhance um the size of neurons the
number of connections between neurons
and maybe even the number of neurons is
to enrich its environment and get it
moving while enriching that environment
you know andrew i think it's it's very
difficult for me to say that the same is
not true in humans and so the first time
this became clear to me was in 2014
um i had an analyst dan pelachar and i
said
dan i'm going to give you a project that
is vexing me to no end which is
um i want you to look at all of the
literature
that we have
both mechanistic and clinical trial data
that talks about alzheimer's prevention
and i want to know every single type of
input and i want to have a clear sense
of
via what mechanism does it offer what
mode of protection
and it took dan and this was obviously
we iterated a lot on this together
and he came back with kind of an amazing
presentation that took almost nine
months to a year of work
and what amazed me was when he came back
to it he said the single greatest
efficacy we can point to is exercise
and i was like damn that's gotta be
nonsense dude there's no way exercise is
the single best thing you can do for the
brain there has to be some drug you've
missed there has to be some other thing
that you've missed
and he's like no like this is hands down
the best thing because you're you know
it's not just what it's doing to be dnf
it's not just what it's doing to
vascular endothelium it's not just what
it's doing to glucose disposal and
insulin signaling all these things like
it's just touching every aspect of the
brain and i was very skeptical for about
six months kind of really pushed on him
and i was like i think you're missing
something dan i think you're missing
something and then finally in the end
looped in richard isaacson who's a
neurologist that we work with really
closely on alzheimer's prevention and
you know ultimately it turned into a
paper that we wrote basically on you
know about this about this this topic
and and and a few others because again i
thought are you sure it's not epa and
dha like that's got to have a bigger
impact and um
again there's a lot of things that i
think do matter and there's a whole host
of things that we do for alzheimer's
prevention
but i think you're absolutely right
there's not one thing that i'll tell
patients is more important than
exercising and by the way it's not
the sort of
pathetic recommendations that are made
like it's you have to exercise a lot
more if you want to get this maximum
benefit you will you will get you know
the maximum benefit comes going from
nothing to something so if you go from
being completely sedentary to doing 15
met hours per week
you'll get
probably a 50 reduction in risk
so a met hour a met just for people who
don't know is a metabolic equivalent so
we're we're exerting about 1.3 mets
sitting here talking if we were sitting
here being quiet it would be about one
met
you know walking really briskly would be
about five mets
so
15 met hours per week would be three one
hour really brisk walks that's not a lot
of work but just going from doing
nothing to doing that
would give you 50
of the benefit that you would get from
going all the way now again i think
i'm personally a little skeptical of how
much that's
i think it's probably a bit less than
that i think there's more upside than
people appreciate
but the studies i don't think can can
truly capture that but
look you know there's there's no reason
to not be exercising more than that and
and capture more benefit even though the
rate at which you accrue it is less and
it also speaks to the health span side
of this which is not necessarily
captured in those data the health span
gets back to the functional piece we
opened with which is what do you want to
be doing in your marginal decade do you
want to be able to pick up a great
grandkid if they come running at you do
you want to be able to get up off the
floor you want to be able to play on the
floor with a kid and then get up
on your own and i think most people are
thinking final years of life they're
trying to think you know how can they um
take themselves to the bathroom they're
thinking how can they sit up
off the toilet i mean yeah like really
basic vegetative type functions right um
at some level
i love this again this idea of marginal
decade and using that as a way to back
cast to uh
to actual
methods and behaviors and
protocols that one should be doing on a
daily basis uh
i'll use anik data as it's now called um
to cite just i know three nobel prize
winners which doesn't mean anything
except that they did beautiful work but
the point is that they're all in their
90s so i'll i'll name them because i'm
complimenting them for what they've done
not just their work but what i'm about
to describe so eric candel at columbia
nobel prize winner for work on memory
torrance and visel work on
neuroplasticity and then richard axel
who's also at columbia nobel prize
winning work for molecular biology of
smellin and molecular biology generally
all three of them
still alive richard's younger compared
to the other two all three of them
either swim jog or play tennis or
racquetball i think is richard's thing
multiple times per week eric was they're
all cognitively still extremely sharp
still interested in the arts doing
science curious about science running
laboratories writing books going on
podcasts i mean it's incredible again
that's anecdata but i was kind of
surprised to learn that colleagues that
were so intellectually strong were also
so obsessed with exercise i mean they
really are obsessed with their exercise
routine and early on linked that to
their um some of their intellectual
vigor over time i want to just also use
it as a jumping off point to ask about
one kind of niche thing but it comes up
um
i don't think i'm gonna out which one of
those told me this but one of those
three individuals um choose an excessive
amount of nicorette
used to be a smoker and i asked him why
and he said because in his
estimation
it's protective against parkinson's and
alzheimer's or at least
the nicotinic acetylcholine
augmentation of nicotine because
nicotine is acetylcholine receptor
obviously
um is known to create a state of focus
and neural enhancement what are your
thoughts about
not smoking let's just i just want to be
really clear people don't smoke nicotine
vape nicotine it's going to shorten your
life just terrible idea addictive etc in
my opinion but
what are your thoughts about
augmenting acetylcholine
through the use of nicotine in order to
keep the brain healthy and focused again
this is one nobel prize winner so it's
truly n of one
but he's so convinced that this matches
up with the mechanistic data on
acetylcholine and cognition that i'd
love to get your thoughts on it so i
can't speak to the ad prevention
component of it i'd have to run that by
a couple of my colleagues who i
collaborate with on that but i can
definitely speak to the cognitive
enhancement piece of it and actually did
an ama on this uh probably a year ago
where i went into all of the gory
details of it and talked about my own
use of of nicotine which i'll cycle on
and off i've been doing it for the last
10 years i haven't what form do you take
it in uh i used to use the gum i don't
like the gum anymore so now i like these
little lozenges um
that uh
i'll tell you a funny story about this
so
our mutual acquaintance david sinclair
mentioned a compete company to me
a year ago he's like hey have you heard
of this company
and i forget the name of the company but
he gave me some name so i go online and
it's like this company's selling
nicotine
and i'm like i wonder why he's asking me
to do this well i'll just order a bunch
and then we'll figure out why because we
were you know there was some reason we
were
doing this potentially through
investment
so i get up like literally ordered like
a lifetime supply of this stuff
and it's pretty good it's actually it's
a really nice little patch because the
thing i didn't like about the gum was i
hated just the the taste of it
um
so then the next week i'm talking to
david i'm like by the way i ordered all
that nicotine stuff you told me about
he's like what
and he goes
oh the company's name was something else
it was totally unrelated it's like oh
god
um so
um
the short answer is i think this stuff
is absolutely a concentration um
enhancing substance um it is addictive
and people need to be wary of that now
it's not addictive to everybody i
personally experience no
um addiction to it whatsoever so i can
i could do it every day for 30 days and
stop and experience no withdrawal i
could forget about it it doesn't really
seem to matter um
you have to be careful with the dose
truthfully i mean remember one cigarette
is about one milligram of nicotine
and a lot of these lozenges will plow
four to eight milligrams into you in one
shot and for someone who is
you know
naive to that like i am
four milligrams is a lot of nicotine in
one bolus so you just have to be very
mindful of it um i got a lot of flack
when i did this ama
for obvious reasons but people were like
how can you as a doctor encourage people
to use nicotine and i was like first of
all i'm not encouraging anybody to use
it i just want to be able to talk about
the biochemistry of it um and if
disclosing that i use it from time to
time is an endorsement then you know i
apologize for that um
but on the list of things that you can
do to make your brain
a little more focused i would consider
this infinitely safer than what a lot of
people are doing which is using
stimulants
i mean to me
i i you know i just tell patients
outright like we are under no
circumstance prescribing stimulants i
mean yeah we're just we're not giving
anybody adderall we're not giving
anybody vivants or any of these things
um not to say they don't have an
appropriate clinical use but they should
be
prescribed under the care of somebody
who's really monitoring the use case for
it and and and using that as a tool to
enhance you know concentration and
cognitive performance is not something
we're comfortable doing yeah it's
rampant on college campuses i can only
imagine um are modafinol modafinil which
are slightly different of course but uh
so
non-clinical use not prescribed for adhd
but just it's rampant recreational use
study-based use but the data i've seen
on modafinil suggests that it only
really provides a no tropic benefit in
someone who is deprived of sleep is
there data that in a
totally well-rested person there is a no
tropic benefit of modafinil i don't know
i have one experience with armadaphenyl
where i took a half a recommended doses
was prescribed by a doctor
i went to give a talk this was in hawaii
and i'm four hours into the talk at my
uh co-speaker came up to me and just
said well first of all you got a little
bit of uh spit in the corner of your
mouth and second of all you haven't
blinked in three minutes and third um
there's only two people left in the
audience i was so lasered in that i kind
of forgot the context i'm a little bit
of a kind of a tunnel vision ocd type
anyway but one that was all it took i
never i never took any more of it it was
a powerful stimulant
i take uh 300 milligrams of alpha gpc
now and again before some cognitive work
sometimes before workouts and i do
subjectively feel that it narrows my
focus in a nice way um but i don't take
it more than once or twice a day and
more than once or twice a week so this
is an example of where you know how
we're talking about exercise versus sort
of nutrition and supplements for
longevity
i think there may be a whole bunch of
things that are kind of interesting
around focus but nothing would compare
to changing our environment like i think
that if i compare my focus today to my
focus when i was in college
there's no comparison like in college i
was truly a robot
but i think a large part of it was there
was no distraction there's no email
there's no social media there's no
internet i mean i was in college when
mosaic launched in the early 90s like i
you know and you had to walk like
a mile to get to the computer lab on a
big sun workstation to do anything
in you know some computer code language
so
when you're sitting in your room
studying there was no distraction and i
think that's a far greater component of
what it means to be focused than the
challenges we have today so
you know my thoughts on this would be
if we really wanted to return to a state
of focus we're going to have to
individually do something about you know
our environment and and i don't know
what the answer is like i've tried every
little trick i can think of like closing
my browsers when i'm writing and stuff
but you know i'm just not strong enough
willed like i'll pick up my phone every
20 minutes to look and see if i miss the
text message or something stupid that's
pretty infrequent i did an episode on
habits and looking at the data um it
seems that
people are getting interrupted or
interrupting themselves
about once every three minutes
in the typical workplace now that
typical has changed with a lot more
people working at home i do put my phone
away when i try and work that nothing
focuses me like a deadline
a little bit of fear-based urgency
that's that's it grant deadlines you
know drop deadlines as i call them or
podcasts we're gonna record today that
nothing works quite like it but
such is life um well thanks for that um
offshoot about nicotine um again you're
not recommending it i'm not recommending
it but it's clear that the that
augmenting the acetylcholine system
which is what nicotine does in its
various forms
and some related type pharmacology does
enhance focus and pretty potently so i
think it's going to be an interesting
area for
real clinical trials and things of that
sort
love to chat about hormone therapies and
hormones generally
when robert cepolsky came on the podcast
we talked a little bit about menopause
and the data around menopause he's very
interested in
these findings that i think i'm going to
get this right
that whether or not
women benefit from estrogen therapy to
offset menopause really depends on when
that therapy is initiated
i don't know if you're aware of those
data but he claimed that if they begin
estrogen therapy in the middle to tail
end of menopause
the outcomes can be
quite bad whereas if they initiate those
estrogen therapies as they enter
menopause or even before menopause then
the outcomes can be quite good
i don't know what percentage of the
patients you treat are male versus
female and what ages those patients are
of course but
what are your thoughts about estrogen
therapy for women menopause and hormone
therapies generally for women maybe even
testosterone therapy you hear about that
these days and then we'll talk about men
so our practice is probably
70 30 male female so we have lots of
women and this is a very important topic
it's also probably
let me think i just want to make sure
i'm not being hyperbolic when i say this
yep i don't think i am it's hands down
the biggest screw-up of the entire
medical field in the last 25 years
now again it's possible in the next hour
i'll think of nope there's a bigger
screw-up another another giant yeah but
but i don't think i will i'm pretty
confident
that i won't be able to think of a
bigger
act
of
incompetence than what happened with the
women's health initiative in the late
90s and early 2000s which is effectively
the study
that
turned the entire medical field off
hormone replacement therapy for women
so it's important i think to explain
what the study looked at so this was a
study that was conducted in response to
the
widely held belief
in the 70s and 80s that women should be
placed on hormones as they're uh going
through menopause right menopause is i
guess maybe i'll even take a step back i
don't know how much your audience is
familiar with how estrogen progesterone
work is it worth going into that stuff
probably worth mentioning a bit of the
top contour some of them might be
familiar with it we've done episodes on
estrogen testosterone but frankly as i
think back to those we didn't really go
into the biology of estrogen
testosterone enough
yeah so i mean actually an interesting
aside that i always tell my female
patients who get a kick out of this um
when you look at a woman's labs you'll
see her estrogen her progesterone her
fsh her lh her testosterone her sexual
binding globulin all these things but
based on the units they're reported in
it's a very distorting picture of what
the most
common androgen is in her body if you
actually convert them to the same units
she has much more testosterone in her
body than estrogen
interesting yeah
i did not know that yeah then again i've
never been a woman getting my hormone
profile yeah yeah so even though a
woman's testosterone is much less than a
men than a man's level um it's still
more than she has estrogen in her body
wow so phenotypically right estrogen is
the hormone that's dominating and so
it's the you know she has much higher
estrogen than a man and much lower
testosterone than a man but in absolute
amounts she has more testosterone than
estrogen just worth pointing that out
incredible so um so so you know what
what's happening to a woman from the age
she starts menstruating until she goes
through menopause
outside of pregnancy and birth control
and stuff like that is she has this
cycle you know roughly every 28 days but
it can vary
where at the beginning of her period we
call that day zero her basic her
estrogen and progesterone are very low
you can't measure them
and then what happens is the estrogen
level starts to rise and it rises in
response to a hormone called follicle
stimulating hormone follicle stimulating
hormone fsh that is getting her ready to
ovulate and she ovulates at about the
midpoint of her cycle so if we're just
gonna make the math easy on day 14 she's
going to release a follicle from one of
her ovaries
and the estrogen level is sort of rising
rising rising we love to measure
hormones on day five because i want to
have a standardized way in which i
measure her hormones so
our women know if we're in the business
of trying to understand her hormones the
day her period starts even if it's just
a day of spotting that becomes our
benchmark and then day five i want to
see every hormone on that day and if
everything is going well i know what her
fsh lh estradiol and progesterone should
be on that day
so the estrogen rises starts to come
down a little bit as she ovulates and
then the luteinizing hormone kicks on
because it's now going to prepare her uh
uterus for uh the lining to
accommodate a pregnancy so now you start
to see estradiol go back but now for the
first time progesterone goes up so
progesterone has been doing nothing for
14 days and now it starts to rise and
actually progesterone is the hormone
that's dominating the second half which
is called her
her luteal cycle so the first 14 days is
the follicular cycle second is the
ludial cycle so once you get to about
the halfway point of that which is now
just to do the math 21 days in the body
has figured out if she's pregnant or not
and again most of the time she's not
going to be pregnant so the body says oh
i don't need this lining that i've been
preparing i'm going to shed it so now
progesterone and estrogen start crashing
and the lining is what is being shed and
that is the menses
by the way it's that last seven days of
that cycle that in a susceptible woman
is what creates those pms symptoms
so it's the actually this is something
that you would probably have a better
understanding of than me
there is something about this in a
susceptible woman
where the enormous reduction of
progesterone so quickly is probably
impacting something in her brain so i
think this is a this is a legitimate
thing right i mean it's not like oh
she's crazy because she's having all
these pms symptoms no
um we know that that's the case because
if you put women on progesterone for
those seven days those symptoms go away
so if you can stabilize their
progesterone during the last half of
their ludial phase and sometimes we
would just do it for the entire ludial
phase just put them on a low dose of
progesterone all pms symptoms vanish
very interesting i'll have to look up
where the progesterone receptors are
located in the brain the allen
brain institute now has beautiful
data of insure hybridization which for
folks that don't understand is uh
looking at rna and so where genes and uh
proteins ought to be expressed in the
human brain by using actual human brain
tissue sections as opposed to just mice
so i'll take a look i think yeah some
insight into it
progesterone emotionality link might be
and where where it might exist neural
circuit wise so then
when the estrogen and progesterone reach
their nader again that starts the cycle
so that just that cycle is happening
over and over and over again okay so
it became you know well known in the 50s
that okay a woman's going to stop
menstruating at some point her estrogen
goes down why don't we just give her
estrogen
because that's clearly going to help
with some of the symptoms of menopause
so what what the women experience when
they go through menopause the first
symptoms are what are called vasomotor
symptoms so this is usually in the form
of
night sweats hot flashes uh so and
depending on the woman this can be
really significant right these are women
who can have a hard time sleeping they
can be having hot flashes during the
middle of the day they can wake up
soaked in a pool of sweat
um those tend to pass after a couple of
years and then they get into sort of the
more
long-term complications of menopause so
what we call vaginal atrophy vaginal
dryness and then the stuff that we
talked about a while ago which is the
osteopenia osteoporosis
a lot of women will complain a brain fog
so
i mean
clearly this was an issue and it was
recognized 70 years ago why don't we
give women estrogen back to replace that
hormone
and so
that went on for
a couple of decades maybe less maybe a
decade and then it was realized wait a
minute we were driving up the risk of
uterine cancer
and the reason for that is if you just
give estrogen with no progesterone to
antagonize it you will thicken the
endometrium endlessly and you will
increase the risk of hyperplasia well
you'll you'll definitely undergo
hyperplasia and then ultimately
dysplasia dysplasia is pre-cancerous and
ultimately uh we were seeing that so
people figured out well actually if you
want to give estrogen to a woman who
still has her uterus you have to give
her progesterone as well you have to be
able to have a hormone to oppose the
estrogen and then that became
effectively in the 19 call it the 1970s
ish the standard for
um
for hrt
so in the early 1990s
uh
the nih said look we haven't really
studied this you know we have a ton of
epidemiology that says giving women
hormones seems to be doing really good
things
they feel better so their all their
symptoms go away
uh they seem to have lower risk of heart
disease lower risk of you know
cardiovascular disorder lower risk of
cardiovascular disease lower risk of
bone fractures
um everything seems to get better lower
risk of diabetes but we haven't tested
this in a randomized prospective trial
so let's do this so that became the whi
and it randomized it had two parallel
arms so it had a group for women who did
not have a uterus
uh so these are women that had undergone
hysterectomy for some other reason and
then it had a group for women that did
have their uterus in the first group
there was a placebo arm and then an
estrogen-only arm and in the other group
there was a progesterone plus estrogen
versus a placebo
everything about the way this study was
done is a bit wonky some of it is
justifiable but it's important to
understand
first the women were all way outside of
menopause
so none of these women were started
when you would normally start hrt
and um
there probably are several reasons for
that but one of them is and i think this
is a legitimate reason they wanted hard
outcomes
they wanted to know death rates
and if you're doing this on women in
their 50s you just weren't going to get
it right you couldn't wait too long yeah
you got to wait too long and this was
only going to be like a 7 to 10 year
study so they had to do this on women
who were much older they also
disproportionately took much sicker
women i believe the prevalence and again
i'm going to get some of these numbers
wrong and people are going to get all
phosphorylated but you know i mean i'm
in the ballpark right something like 30
40 of these women were smokers the
prevalence of obesity diabetes was
enormous so they they they really
disproportionately picked the most
unhealthy population they could that was
pretty advanced in age and again i think
part of that was to say look we want to
make sure that after seven years we
really know if there's a difference in
these causes of death
the other thing is
this is kind of weird although again i i
understand their rationale for it but
this is a great example of be very
careful when you look at a clinical
trial
that it remotely represents the patients
you're interested in treating so they
also treated no patients who were
symptomatic
the rationale being if we include in the
study patients who are symptomatic those
who are randomized to placebo will drop
out
okay it makes sense in terms of study
design makes no sense if the study
design is um
intended to mimic the real world that's
right so now let's just keep track of
the three issues we have a
disproportionately unhealthy patient
population who are not symptomatic
and we're starting them more than 10
years after menopause
the next thing that they did which again
i understand why they did it but it's
now the fourth strike against this study
is and i've spoken with the pi of the
study and asked this question point
blank i'm actually going to have her on
my podcast at some point soon to go over
this in more detail
is why did you use conjugated equine
estrogen and mpa which is a synthetic
form of progesterone horse
yes estrogen of course it's horse urine
they collect horse urine so they're
getting the it's horses do urinate a lot
or at least when they urinate it seems
like a large volume of urine from what
i've observed
you have a lot of experience with this
no but you know my sister rode horses
for a little while my high school
girlfriend had a horse and that thing i
mean the
the bees were legendary
male horse yeah yeah
so yeah so so the the conjugated equine
estrogen is the estrogen that's
collected from from female horses and
then it's a synthetic progesterone
uh and i said to to uh to to the person
i said well why didn't you use what we
use today which is bioidentical estrogen
and progesterone like today
when we put women on estrogen we use a
it's an fda product called the vivelle
dot so it's a patch that you just put on
and it's estradiol but it's bioidentical
estradiol and we use what's called
micronized progesterone so bioidentical
progesterone
and she said
well at the time we just wanted to test
what was currently being used i said
totally makes sense but again now you
have four considerations that you have
to keep in mind okay so despite those
four considerations and i'm going to
make a case for you why i think the mpa
created a real problem in that study the
synthetic
when
the preliminary results
were first made available but not yet
peer reviewed and not yet published
there was a huge
fiasco huge press announcement about it
suggesting that the women receiving
the cee plus mpa
in the
group with the uterus had a higher
incidence of breast cancer
and that basically became the headline
that never went away though it turned
out not to be true
let's talk about the numbers what was
the increase in the risk of breast
cancer in that group which gets to my
one of my if you know you've ever
listened to me on the podcast rail on
something listen i have about 3 800 pet
peeves and counting my laboratory staff
know these um know a good number of them
so here i'll do not have to apologize
for having many pet peeves because as
long as they have um experience and data
to support them it provides so one of my
biggest pet peeves is
uh and my my team knows this because
sometimes they'll occasionally you know
they'll do this and i'll have to remind
them you never talk about a relative
risk change without an absolute risk
accommodating it right so so what does
that look like so the the relative risk
increase of breast cancer in the
estrogen plus mpa group versus the
placebo was
25 27
and that became the only headline
hrt increases risk of breast cancer by
27
now
i don't think that's true at all today
but let's even look at the data what was
the arr what was the absolute risk
increase
it was a difference between five cases
per thousand and four cases per thousand
so the arr was zero point one percent
one case in a thousand
and it's true going from four in a
thousand to five in a thousand is a 25
increase
but it's a completely inappropriate
context i agree and i feel like
headlines of that sort
which have come up recently around
various dietary interventions we won't
go there at least for not for the time
being
are nothing short of criminal because
they really
distort people's thinking but also they
steer the course of science and medicine
for as you pointed out for decades
if not longer and they can really take
us off our health track in serious ways
so i'll bring this meandering to a close
which is to say even though i could
spend the next hour talking about all of
the ways in which this study was flawed
and all of the very unethical things
that were done by a number of the
investigators who went out of their way
to mask the truth of this study from the
world
i'll tell a woman today
we're going to start you on this when
you're going through menopause we're
using
bioidentical hormones
and
if your upper bound risk of breast
cancer is one one case in a thousand you
should at least weigh that against all
of the other benefits which i'll talk
about now there's something else i want
to say because a moment ago i alluded to
the fact that i think the mpa might have
been the biggest issue in that study so
there were two findings in that study
that were negative
one was the small increase in the risk
of heart disease and a small increase in
the risk of breast cancer but consider
the other group we forgot about the
group that didn't have a uterus because
remember those women got estrogen only
versus placebo what was the difference
in breast cancer there
well this is interesting because it
didn't reach statistical significance
but its p-value was 0.06 or 0.07 so it
came very close but it was in the
opposite direction
it was a 24 risk reduction
about one in a thousand as well
so when you had estrogen plus mpa you
had uh barely statistically significant
the p-value was 0.05 so it just hit
statistical significance one in a
thousand cases for breast cancer and
then you had one in a thousand cases but
p value of .07 for reduction of risk of
breast cancer which to me suggests that
the mpa the synthetic progesterone was
playing more of a role than anything
else
the second thing i point out is
oral estrogen which we no longer use
does increase coagulability
it does increase the ability of the
blood to clot a little bit and when we
look at the more recent data on hrt
using topical estrogen or patches of
estrogen we don't see that at all in
fact we see the opposite now so now we
see the risk of heart disease going down
in women with estradiol and some women
will be arriving to those treatments
with mutations and things like factor
five lidan and other clotting factors
is it
uh appropriate to say that everyone both
male and female should know whether or
not they have mutant forms of factor
five leiden you know we don't typically
test people for factor five uh my wife
actually has it but we didn't learn it
until she had help syndrome giving birth
to our first daughter um
but um
you know we kind of look for more family
history reason to be testing things like
that uh we take a pretty detailed family
history so we'll kind of look for
clotting issues there what about um
so
your reflex nowadays is to
put women on
uh
these topical estrogens
basically have the discussion right so
so here's where we still struggle right
is you know
we
if it were up to me i'd prefer for a
woman's hrt to be provided by her gyn
because we want to be able to work in
partnership with the gyn who we would
like to see an endometrial ultrasound
done every year um that's you know some
would argue that's overkill but you know
we think she'd be showing a pap smear
every year as well so if we're looking
at the cervix we want to look at the
endometrium we want to make sure the
lining isn't too thick the other thing i
should say andrew is today
we now realize that not all women can
tolerate estrogen pardon me progesterone
so you have to be careful so assuming
again a woman still has her uterus the
estrogen solves most of the problems but
then you have to decide can she tolerate
the progesterone and it needs to be if
given systemically like 100 to 200
milligrams and for some women that is a
life-saving intervention i mean they
start sleeping better their hair gets
thicker they feel better but for some
women it literally drives them crazy
it's probably the reciprocal of what we
were seeing in the case of women with
pms so in those situations
we say great we're done with oral
progesterone we just use a progesterone
coded iud
so then you get the local progesterone
in the uterus for protection and the
systemic estrogen
fascinating what about um
oral contraception um
for in women
so the use of estrogen chronically
through people's you know college years
or 20s 30s maybe even teens who knows um
what's known about the long-term effects
if any
i got to be honest i don't i don't think
i know enough to comment on it it's not
it's not something that really impacts
my patient population um
you know
at least in what i see more women are
using iuds for uh for for contraception
than than ocs i mean we use ocs
sometimes in women who are
pre-menopausal for symptomatic control
but we'll typically use like a low low
estrogen so a very low
synthetic estrogen which i don't like
using these very much but if it's the
only thing we can get to control certain
symptoms and we'll use it like half her
cycle
um
but
it's typically not something we're that
experienced with what about testosterone
because you mentioned that you know
nanogram
per ml uh
when you set everything to the same um
you know i guess it's nanogram per
deciliter as it would be to to kind of
normalize everything
per mole right yeah and so yeah that's
what peter was pointing out before is
that you look at your charts and they're
all in these different measures and so
when you normalize testosterone is
actually higher than estrogen in women
that's a surprise to me um
do you prescribe testosterone therapy to
women ever we do sometimes but i do it
with much more caution because i don't
have the data right so where i'll
you know
what we'll say is look i mean we're now
really outside of an area where i can
point to a lot of data like when it
comes to estrogen and progesterone
i'll i'll happily go toe-to-toe with
anybody who wants to make the case that
it's dangerous uh similarly when it
comes to using testosterone in men i'll
i'll spend all day and i can go through
that literature until the other person
cries and wants to just call uncle right
when it comes to prescribe them
testosterone when it comes to estrogen
and testosterone and women don't have
that data
and i'd love to see that trial done so
how what's the
what's the sweet spot how do we how do
we reconcile that so um it's not
something i consider standard and
basically if a woman is for testosterone
first of all is staggeringly low
and again even though her testosterone
is low compared to a male we still have
a range so if it's really at the bottom
of that range she's really having
difficulty putting on muscle mass and
really complaining of low libido
i think in that situation we'll go ahead
and use topical testosterone um
and and
you know replace her to a level that is
still physiologically normal yeah that's
key because when people hear hrt they
think about super physiological seems to
be the term yeah like i've never seen a
single symptom in a single woman that
i've put testosterone on in terms of
like acne body hair things like that
like those are real symptoms that you
have to be aware of but you know like
clitoral enlargement and things like
that like that doesn't happen under
physiologic normal conditions
i'd love to talk a little bit about
hormone replacement therapy in men um
when one looks on social media and the
internet there seems to be a younger and
younger cohort of guys
people in their teens and twenties
showing up to the table thinking
uh that injecting testosterone scipione
or taking anavar or whatever it is is
going to be the right idea they're
mainly seem to be focused on cosmetic
effects
i'm not a physician so i can't say
whether or not they were actually
hypocritical et cetera but it seems to
me
you can correct me if i'm wrong but it
seems to me that similar to the atiyah's
rule as it relates to longevity that we
could come up with a broad contour rule
in which
if a male of any age is not trying to
get decent sleep exercise appropriately
appropriate nutrition mining their
social connections etc etc the idea of
going straight to testosterone seems
like a bad idea that said
just like with depression and
antidepressants there is a kind of a
cliff after which
low enough testosterone or low enough
serotonin prevents people from sleeping
exercise social connection etc so i do
want to acknowledge that but
with that in mind how do you think about
and perhaps occasionally prescribe
and direct your patients in terms of
hormone replacement therapy in men a
person in their 30s person in their 40s
who's doing almost all the other things
correctly
what sorts of levels do you think are
meaningful because the range is
tremendous in terms of blood tests 300
nanograms per deciliter i think on the
low end now in the us all the way up to
900 or 1200 that's an enormous range
what are some of the other hormones you
like to look at estrogen dht and so on
so um
a lot to unpack there so um
let's start with the ranges right so um
the the the ranges you gave are for
total testosterone of course
and we don't spend a lot of time looking
at that uh the way we used the way we
you know i used to spend more time
looking at total and free when i had
when i used more tricks to modulate it
so i'm actually far more simple in my
manipulation of testosterone today than
i was six or seven years ago six or
seven years ago
i mean
we were you know we would use a micro
dose of anavar to lower
shbg in a person who had normal
testosterone but low free testosterone
what what was a low dose of anabar in
that context 10 milligrams subling
two to three times a week
n of our basically being dht
it oxandra
exactly and again we're not recommending
this it's actually if you're playing a
competitive sport it can get you banned
from that spirit yeah
it can also get you banned from having
children if you do it incorrectly yeah
so a micro dose of this has to be small
enough that it doesn't impair your
body's ability to make testosterone but
anavar has such a high affinity for shbg
that it basically
distracts your shbg from binding your
testosterone freeing up testosterone
that's exactly right so so the goal was
how do i just give you more free
testosterone so if a patient shows up
and they've got a
total testosterone of 900 nanograms per
deciliter which would place them at you
know depending on the scale you look at
the scale we look at that would place
you at about the 70th percentile but
your free testosterone is you know eight
nanograms per deciliter so that's pretty
bad that means you're less than one
percent free a guy should be about two
percent free tea
so that dude should be closer to 16 to
18 nanograms per deciliter
so in that situation that i just gave
you his shbg is really high his shbg is
probably in the 80 to 90 range that's
very high yeah because i think the upper
range is somewhere around 55 56 exactly
so we would first back stall for what's
driving his shbg
so there's basically three hormones so
genetics plays a huge role in this
there's no question that
just out of the box people have a
different like set point for shbg mine
is incredibly low my shbg is like kind
of in the 30s 20s to 30s
but from a hormone perspective there's
basically three hormones that run it so
estradiol being
probably the most important insulin and
thyroxine
so we're going to look at all of those
and decide if any of those are playing a
role so insulin suppresses it so this is
actually the great irony of helping a
person get metabolically healthy is in
the short run you can actually lower
their free testosterone all things equal
because as insulin comes down shbg goes
up and if testosterone hasn't gone up
with it you're lowering free
testosterone so somebody who goes on a
very low carbohydrate diet and attempt
to drop some water and drop some weight
is going to increase their shbg yeah if
their insulin goes bind up testosterone
less free testosterone um i can i could
tell the carnivore diet people are going
to be coming after me with um with bone
marrow in hand but then again that after
this discussion extends a little further
i'm sure the vegans will be coming after
me with celery stalks so it's a
uh so then the same as with estrodial so
except in the opposite direction so
higher estradiol is higher shbg
um so again occasionally you'll see a
guy with incredible normal testosterone
but he's a very high aromatase
activity person so he has a lot of the
enzyme that converts testosterone into
estradiol you can lower estrodial a bit
with an aromatase inhibitor and that can
bring down shbg now again these things
individually are rarely enough to move
the needle
the last is thyroxine so if you have a
person whose thyroid is out of whack you
have to fix that before you if their t4
is out of whack you're going to
interfere with that shbg
there are also some supplements which i
think you've probably talked about these
on the podcast i feel like i've heard
you talk about these in the podcast yeah
there are a few that will adjust you
know there is this idea now there's a
much better review it just came out i'll
send it to you i'd love your thoughts on
it and i've been perusing it line by
line
but i love input
from experts like you on
the use of tonga ali
for reducing hpg in my experience it
does free up some testosterone
by which mechanism it isn't exactly
clear and the effects aren't that
dramatic yeah right they're probably
multiple effects for all we know it
increases libido and it does generally
by way of increasing estrogen slightly
which can also increase libido in some
individuals so we don't know the exact
motive of action so we've talked about a
few the one that a few years back people
were claiming could uh reduce shbg was
um uh stinging metals um stinging nettle
well just urine seems to be urinating
seems to be coming up multiple times on
this podcast for whatever reason uh
stinging nettle extract i took the the
most pronounced effect of that was you
could basically urinate over a car and
when taking shpg what the underlying
mechanism of that was i do not know i
took it for a short while it didn't drop
my shpg very much um but it did drop by
dht sufficiently so that i stopped
taking it i do not like anything that
impedes dht
i i don't care if my hairline retreats i
don't care about any of that dht to me
is something to be um coveted and held
on to because you feel so much better
when your dht is in the appropriate
range and love your thoughts on that
yeah at some point it really depends on
the guy and it depends on what risk
you're trying to manage right so
prostate size starts to become one of
the issues with dht luckily my prostate
specific antigen is low um and dht
um the things i know can reduce it are
things like finasteride propecia things
like testosterone right things to that
people take to try and avoid hair loss
can dramatically reduce dht and leads
all sorts of terrible sexual side
effects mood-based side effects etc but
um yeah so i'm not aware of anything
that can be taken in supplement form
that can really profoundly drop yeah we
don't spend much attention on it anymore
basically
i used to have a much more complicated
differential diagnosis eight years ago
like i i mean it was i would drive
patients nuts with the whiteboard
diagrams i would draw for them and in
the end i think they were just like dude
just what do i need to take um today we
take a much more simple approach so the
first question is should you or should
you have your free testosterone being
higher that's the metric i care about is
free testosterone is the first most
important the second most important is
estradiol and sorry in trouble you said
if you look at your total testosterone
you want the free tea to be about two
percent of your well it should be right
now i can't i might not change that
anymore so in other words if a guy's at
one percent then i know i have to really
boost his total testosterone if he's
only going to get one to one and a half
percent of it converted to free i need
to boost him and that's why i don't care
if he's outside the range like i'll have
a guy who's free tea
i might have to get a guy's total tea up
to 1500 to get his free tea to 18. i see
so free tea is the target i like t is
what we treat and do you still use
antivarix uh um alexandra sorry to try
and lower shbg
because it's too potent no because it's
just too complicated for patients you
know you know it's a it's a it's a drug
that can't be taken orally so you have
to take it under the tongue
or something right but then you know i
had one patient once who even though we
told him about 87 times that he was like
swallowing the anavars and his liver
function and he was like we're talking
10 milligrams three times a week is a
tiny dose and three months of him or
whatever two months of him swallowing
that every time
tripled his liver function test so it's
like it's just i was like you know it's
just not worth the hassle of doing this
um for you know perfection uh in reality
we can fix this another way so so the
first order question is
do we believe clinically you will
benefit from
normalizing your free testosterone or
taking it to
a level let's call it 80th to 90th
percentile so upper normal limit of
physiologic ranges
that's the first order question and
that's going to come down to symptoms
and that's going to come down to some
biomarkers i think there's
two years ago two years ago or maybe a
year ago a very good study came out that
looked at pre-diabetic men
you've probably talked about this study
and looking at insulin resistance and
glucose disposal with and without
testosterone and the evidence was
overwhelmingly clear
testosterone improves
glycemic control testosterone improves
insulin signaling this shouldn't be
surprising by the way given the role
muscles play as a glucose reservoir in a
glucose sync so now i include that as
one of the things that we will consider
as a factor for using testosterone now
again it's not the only one so you can
accomplish that with exercise unit
accomplished these other things but then
you get into a little bit of the vicious
cycle of will having a normalized
testosterone facilitates you doing those
things better
so uh let's just assume we come to the
decision that this this this person is a
good candidate for for testosterone
replacement therapy
the next question is what's the method
we're going to do it are we going to do
it indirectly or directly
now
we used to use a lot of clomid in our
practice um and have you talked about
clomid on the phone i talked too much
about it i'm um no we've talked a little
bit about the fact that some people
taking things like anastrozole to reduce
aromatase activity run can potentially
run into trouble because they think oh
well more testosterone good lower
estrogen bad and then they end up with
issues like joint pain memory issues and
severe drops in libido and i think a lot
of the reasons and even fat accumulation
so if estrogen is too low you'll you can
develop adiposity in a way that you
wouldn't otherwise there's a great new
england journal paper
it's probably ten years old now that
looked at
fi uh i believe it was five different
doses of testosterone scipione so these
men were chemically castrated and
divided into ten groups it's pretty
remarkable somebody signed up for the
study yeah so you were with and without
an astrozole and five doses of
testosterone okay so now you basically
had five testosterone levels plus or
minus high or low estradiol and the
results were really clear that the
higher your testosterone and the more
your estradiol was in kind of that 30 to
50 range the better you were so if
estrogen was too low even in the
presence of high testosterone the
outcomes were less significant and this
is 30 to 50 nanograms per deciliter not
30 to 50 percent of your of one's
testosterone okay great um
okay so we haven't talked but clomid is
no we have not talked a lot about clomid
i'd love to get your thoughts on clomid
so clumpfein is a fertility drug it's a
synthetic hormone it's actually two
drugs m cloniphene and i forget the
other one
and it tells the pituitary
uh to secrete fsh and lh
so
you and so the advantage of clomid is
it's oral
and it's meant to be taken orally so
you know a typical starting dose would
be like 50 milligrams three times a week
and if you do that you'll notice in most
men especially young men fshlh goes up
in any man the fsh and lh go up but if a
man still has testicular reserve he'll
make lots of testosterone in response to
that um because that's the first order
question we're trying to answer is do
you
is your failure to make testosterone
central or peripheral yeah and i think
uh just one point out again correct me
if i'm wrong but my understanding is
that a lot of the drugs that we're
talking about
um the synthetic compounds testosterone
estrogen things
related to growth hormone etc were
discovered and designed in order to
treat and excuse me in order to isolate
and treat exactly these kinds of
syndromes whether or not it was the
hypothalamus the pituitary or the target
tissue the ovaries or the or the testes
correct correct yeah i mean i think the
easiest way to go about doing this is
just give the hormone that's that's
missing without attention to where it's
where the deficiency is why this becomes
relevant is
if you have a 35 year old guy whose
testosterone is low
but you can demonstrate that it's low
because he's not getting enough of a
signal from the pituitary why would you
bother giving him more testosterone when
he has the capacity he has the latex
cells and the stratus cells to make
testosterone he just needs the signal
um sometimes though not always just a
course of clomid can wake him up
and he's he's back to making normal
testosterone so he'll do this three
times a week 50 ml uh 50 milligrams
three times a week for a short course
and then yeah we would do it for eight
to twelve weeks and then we re-evaluate
and estrogen and testosterone will
increase in in parallel yes
and again it depends you know aromatase
activity is dependent on how much body
fat you have and genetics um and if
estradiol gets too high we think if it
gets over about 55 60 we will give
microdoses of an astrazol but it has to
be real microdoses i mean you cannot
pound people with an astrozole to give
you perspective
the the the sort of
on label use like if you just go to a
pharmacy and order an astrozole you're
going to get one milligram tablets like
we can't give anybody a milligram and
they'll feel like garbage we have to
have it compounded at 0.1 milligrams and
we might give a patient point one two to
three times a week that would be a big
dose of anastrozole
yeah i think that the typical trt clinic
out there
is giving 200 milligrams per mil one mil
200 milligrams of testosterone once
every two weeks and then hitting people
with um multiple milligrams of
anastrozole and they're all over the
place i i've never really understood i
mean i guess i shouldn't be surprised
but it's kind of blows my mind that
these trt clinics are up all over the
place given how bad i mean i see the
results because i have patients that
come from them
and i don't understand like why they're
so incompetent
i actually think it's worse than that i
think that they simply don't understand
and don't care
because it's a
pill mill and it's a money mill i think
that nowadays it seems almost everybody
who's doing trt is taking lower doses
more frequently every other day or twice
a week dividing the dose and being very
very careful with these estrogen or
aromatase blockers um we most of our
patients do not take aromatase
inhibitors it's not needed it's really
only the high aromatizers that need it
um
and so yeah when we'll talk about
testosterone we'll talk about dosing
there because i agree the more
frequently you can take it the better
and frankly you don't need to go more
frequently than twice a week
because it's so slow
yeah the half-life of the drug is i
think it's about three and a half days
is the plasma half-life or something
like that it could be off a little bit
but but twice week dosing is is really
nice so if you're
if you if you go to like a you know a
testosterone clinic that's giving you
200 every two weeks 50 twice a week is
the same total dose which by the way is
a physiologic dose that's not going to
give somebody any of the side effects
you would see you're not going to get
acne with that you're not going to get
gynecomastia you're not going to get
anything the only real side effect you
get from that is you will get testicular
atrophy that is enough to suppress yeah
to maintain um fertility what do you
typically do for well so this is where
so i'll finish the story on clomid
because we currently do not use clomid
and that's that's um
due to a really interesting observation
that um we we made that i don't think
has been reported in the literature yet
which is that
clomid was increasing levels of a sterol
that we also happen to measure called
desmosterol and i'm not familiar with
that
so in the in the in the way that
cholesterol is made uh it's made by um
there's two pathways that make
cholesterol so it starts like with you
know two carbon subunits like acetyl coa
and it kind of marches down a pathway
bifurcates and cholesterol is the
finished product of both
but in one of those pathways the the
molecule right before cholesterol is
called desmosterol and the other pathway
it's called lithosterol so we constantly
measure lithosterol and desmosterol
because we want to know how much
cholesterol is being synthesized in the
body not just what your cholesterol is
we want to know how much cholesterol you
reabsorb
and those markers are really important
to us when we're looking at
cardiovascular disease risk
so
when we gave patients clomid we were
noticing a
almost universal rise in their
desmosterol levels
now the most obvious explanation for
that though i
the last time i looked i couldn't find
clear explanation for this in any of the
clinical like the clinical trials that
led to the approval of clomid so i don't
know if it was described in fact maybe
it wasn't known i suspect it is
inhibiting the enzyme which i think is
called delta 24 desaturates that turns
desmosterol into cholesterol
makes sense if you inhibit that enzyme
you're going to see a rise in
desmosterol
this wouldn't have been a concern to me
if not for the fact that tom dayspring
who's one of the physicians we work with
who's one of the world's experts in
lipids pointed out a very obscure story
which was that the very first drug ever
approved to treat
cardiovascular disease at least to treat
hypercholesterolemia was a drug that
attacked the same enzyme
so this this this is in the early 1960s
i believe maybe the mid-60s this drug
was approved and it lowered
cholesterol
and it was approved on the basis of
lowering cholesterol now today no drug
for ascvd is approved on the basis of it
lowering cholesterol that's not a high
enough bar you have to reduce events you
actually have to show that you're
preventing heart attacks and death
but at the time it was like hey it
lowers cholesterol it's got to be good
well in the late 60s it was pulled from
the market because events were going up
so cholesterol was coming down events
were going up how could that be
we don't know
what we are
suspecting is that desmosterol which is
still a sterol
was potentially more damaging
and created more oxidative stress in the
endothelium in the sub-endothelial space
than cholesterol
which would at least suggest to us and
again we're taking a lot of leaps here
that maybe having high desmoseral very
high desmosterol is not a good thing
and so
once we kind of pieced all that together
a few years ago we were like yeah we're
just not going to prescribe clomid
anymore
um
and
we then switched to hcg which we used to
use sometimes instead of clomid but it's
more cumbersome to work with it needs to
be refrigerated it's a much more fragile
molecule yeah i think we talked about
this once it's almost like if you if you
accidentally uh knock over the little uh
bottle it's basically gone bad travel
with it is very generous with it
um it's a needle you know it's an
injection sub-q so easy to administer
it's not im or anything like that but
it's just more of a hassle factor
but that said it has the benefit that
clomid does which is it preserves
testicular function it preserves
testicular volume
so you know bodybuilders will often use
this in their post cycle therapy as a
way to kind of recover function and we
would just use it now as ongoing therapy
for a guy who still has testicular
reserve so on its own no testosterone no
aromatase inhibitor nothing just a way
to crank out a bit more testosterone
from the testes maybe some additional
estrogen hcg is a different model
hcg is just an analog of luteinizing
hormone so it's basically like giving
them luteinizing hormone so it's going
to crush endogenous luteinizing hormone
levels right because it's actually um
yeah and and it um you don't really see
much of an impact on lh but you do see
endogenous testosterone production go
down actually no i correct that both fsh
and lh will go down on a high enough
dose yep uh just as i mentioned and here
i'm not making recommendations but one
supplement i've talked a lot about uh
publicly is fedoja agrestus which is
this weird nigerian shrub
that um talk about this on tim's podcast
on tim's podcast and joe's podcast and
um you know there was a bit of a
backlash because it does turn out that
at high doses in rodent studies it can
cause
some toxicity to the testes
but um at lower doses it does seem to
increase luteinizing hormone and after
talking about this a number of people
went out there did pre and post blood
work and the consistent effect seems to
be an increase in luteinizing hormone
there's a noticeable effect on test
testicular size and volume so a lot of
people take this and like oh you know
their balls are getting bigger and so
they get all excited that something good
is happening um but we don't know the
long-term safety and efficacy of
something like fedojo whether or not it
needs to be psychological this is why
i'm i'm also very leery of the
supplements in this space because at
least when we're using hcg
or testosterone like we have
so many years of data you have to
remember how many women are using this
stuff for reproductive medicine
so i you know i think the fdi the fda
has a lot of faults uh
i think i have an entire podcast devoted
to the corruption of the fda and all of
the mistakes that have been made with
respect to their oversight in especially
generic drugs
but it's way more regulated than the
wild wild west of nutty supplement land
uh absolutely i think that the reason
we're talking about things like tongada
and padoja was to provide some
intermediate discussion between
doing all the correct things but no
supplementation or hormone therapy and
then going straight to hormone therapy
it's sort of like the leap from i can't
focus very well to ritalin right without
a a real diagnosis of adhd to oh well
maybe some things like alpha gpc low
doses of nicotine right but i agree
entirely i mean the sourcing is
important the dosages are are worked out
empirically on an individual basis and
there aren't randomized control trials
there there just aren't yeah and and you
know have kind of like a
a seven
uh this is another peter principle right
so i've got a lot of patients that come
into the practice and you know during
our intake we go through
what what drugs and supplements are you
taking right now and a lot of people
come in i'm not taking anything peter i
just you're in you're in charge now like
tell me what you think and then you get
a lot of people that come in and they're
like uh we're gonna need an extra few
pages for this part of the documentary
people who travel with a suitcase that
you can hear as they walk through the
airport from all the pills
so i give these patients a little
homework exercise which is you have to
answer these seven questions for every
supplement you take and here's the
spreadsheet and let's talk about it
and it basically just runs through like
you know it's it's basically walking you
through the logic of why do you take
this molecule
and um
i think for many people it's when they
do that it's very sobering right they
kind of a lot of them will come back and
be like you know what
i don't think i can come up with any
reason along this really rigorous line
of thinking as to why i'm taking 80 of
this stuff well i know people and
actually we know some of the same people
were fanatic about like red life red
light on the testes sunning their testes
um putting ice packs on their testes
it's kind of all over the place the
number of things that people are trying
and doing in order to increase
testosterone output from their testes is
pretty remarkable and that said
um among some of the women i know the
number of things that they're doing to
try and promote longevity and fertility
and in particular skin health hair
health and nail health
is also kind of outrageous everything
from collagen to red light therapies
which may actually have some efficacy in
certain cases but um as an interesting
there's a hunger there right oh for sure
one of the things that i hope gets a lot
more attention is the use of rapamycin
for preserving ovarian health so the
animal literature on this is pretty
pretty impressive right so in mouse
models rapamycin will preserve
ovarian life
and so it makes sense right i mean it
totally makes sense why
the most potent gero-protective molecule
we have would also preserve and extend
ovarian life at least in mice so
i'd love to see the clinical trials done
in in women to test this hypothesis i
definitely want to come back to this
because that's a key thing i know a lot
of people are interested in female
fertility out there um including their
male partners so um
going back to so now i understand why
you don't prescribe clomiphene because
of this um
this monstro uh potential desmosterol
link um
what about testosterone therapy so less
less frequent lower doses um
less
less or no estrogen inhibition or
aromatase
we're only using an aromatase blocker
and we use aromatics when we do
it's just it's just to get that
estradiol into the range we want i like
to see it between 30 and 50. that that's
the sweet spot and
uh i don't know i would say like a third
maybe a
not even a third i'd say probably 20
percent of men require a micro dose of
anastrozole to get into that range most
do not
um and i'd rather err on the side of
being a little high than a little low so
i never really want to be below 25
if
unless sometimes it's just below 25 and
it is it is what it is that's fine but
but if we're suppressing it to below 25
i never want to be in that zone um and
then yes so trt is ultimately you know
giving testosterone scipione is usually
what we use injectable so as opposed to
cream or pellet
correct um i used to use pellets with
women
um
for some who were really adamant about
the convenience of it
but
for a bunch of reasons i i just i'm
mostly not doing that and i've never
been a fan of pellets in men
um you can't control the dosages once
it's same i know the dose yeah that's
obviously a problem but i don't think
there's a big difference between putting
a pellet into a man and a woman so when
you're putting an estrogen pellet into a
woman it's like
it's that big
when you're putting enough pellets into
a man for six months of testosterone
it's two sums of pellets that are longer
than my finger so you're putting like a
v why are you putting this you're
putting it into the gluteal fat
so it's just it's just a more morbid
procedure and i don't think it's
necessary i think if you if you know how
to manage it you know through through
sort of the injections and now is no big
deal yeah well especially now if you're
doing you know we're having them do
sub-q injections anyway so it's not im
they're using uh 5 8 inch to a 1 inch 25
gauge needle which is about the smallest
needle you can push the oil through
um
once to twice a week depending on and by
the way if they're real needle phobes we
use zyasted which is a pre-loaded pen
and
are you having all men take hcg to
maintain fertility and testosterone
got it yeah and by the way we do not
like to use trt and men who we don't
like to use testosterone specifically
and men who still want to maintain
fertility we just steer them away from
that because total sperm count goes down
yeah we just say why risk it like we'd
rather use hcg
just on its own yeah just wait just wait
until you're done reproducing bank sperm
wait till you're done reproducing before
we go to testosterone
um what are some of the benefits
and what are some of the uh cautionary
notes with
appropriate trt meaning of the kind of
contour that we're talking about here a
lower dose with the
yes or no
low estrogen control um
people
what it generally people report how do
they feel
what does it allow them to do that they
couldn't do or feel before and then in
terms of
what are the markers to look for is it
ldl blood pressure
water retention acne those kinds of
things are there some other things it
depends on the doses right i mean again
we're using these in really low doses so
it's pretty rare that we'd have a
patient on more than 100 milligrams a
week of testosterone um i think for
comparison like a bodybuilder could
easily take 500 to 1000 during a high
growth phase i know some of these guys
they they go ballistic or they're doing
moderate levels of testosterone and
sippy nate but they're also taking
dianabol alexandralone uh
you know sarms and a bunch of other
things i mean their stacks are kind of
ridiculous i mean not no disrespect to
that sport but i mean people it's just
been like crazy in that sport right
outside of physiology yeah and i think
for 99 people listening they just they
look when they hear bodybuilder and they
just like why would somebody do that
anyway right i think that's the typical
so the point is a lot of but but we owe
those guys a great deal of gratitude
because they've shown us the boundaries
including the women that's right yeah
yeah and so so so
those those bodybuilders have taught us
a lot about
like
what happens and so yeah the the the
bloating the
water retention acne hair loss hair
growth all of those things we understand
the truth of it is we just don't see
those things in our patients but 100
milligrams per week is a very low i'll
put my interest it's a physiologic dose
i mean the reality is it's enough for
most people i mean there's probably the
highest we've ever had to go is maybe
70 twice a week what's the youngest
patient you've ever had to put um on trt
actual testosterone
probably i asked a question about maybe
maybe maybe 40.
i think that's great for people to hear
because i know that a lot of guys in
their 20s are thinking trt is the way to
go and i would argue unless you're doing
everything else right and you're still
hypocritical and you're really
struggling put that and put that time
off because also the fertility issue you
want to delay well again it depends if
when we say trt if you're in your 20s
and there's no other way i would i would
hope you would be steered toward hcg to
at least preserve testicular function
now again we don't actually know if
after being on hcg for 10 years
your pituitary will still work right you
won't be able to make your own
luteinizing exactly so so it might be
the case that you're going to need
something upstream of that like clomid
to kickstart it and then we're but again
i i don't know i don't want anybody
who's listening to this who's using
clomid for fertility to think that
there's anything wrong with it i was my
concern over this became like if you're
going to be on this for 10 years is it
problematic not if you're using this for
a course of ivf or something like that
so so again if if we felt that someone's
pituitary was not working i would be
happy to put three months of clomid on
them to kind of try to see if we could
blast it back do you have men cycle on
and off testosterone at these low
dosages are they taking a month vacation
from it everywhere yeah it totally
depends you know i was talking to a
patient yesterday where
we're going to do we just decided to
change the cycle eight weeks on then
eight weeks on hcg eight weeks on and
eight weeks on hcg so that's going to be
a cycle that maintains his testosterone
level but fluctuates between endogenous
exogenous endogenous exogenous sometimes
we'll just do testosterone on off on off
and there it's like how much can he
replenish naturally but understanding
his tea will dip during those off cycles
seems to me there's a tremendous
incentive for somebody to develop a
molecule that can directly target shbg
besides oxandralone anamar right if one
could just drop shbg just the tiniest
bit it seems like one could adjust the
free t
um
in it in a way that would be great i
don't know why that molecule's so hard
to target but somebody ought to do it
the chemistry can't be that i talked
with patrick arnold about this many many
years ago
um i wish i could remember what his
id he he had a comment about this that
at the time made sense and i don't
remember what it was because i i had
that thought too like
man
especially for that subset of guys who
have normal testosterone but they're
just over binding it
i'm really glad that you brought up this
issue of total testosterone versus free
tea and the reason is um ever since
going on podcasts and talking about this
stuff and talking about on this podcast
people will send me their numbers
they'll send me their charts and then
they'll send photos of themselves and i
can tell you while i'm not a clinician
and i haven't done fancy statistics on
it there's very little correlation
between someone's absolute testosterone
and how they appear i mean some of these
guys look you know
really lean really strong and they'll
say oh total testosterone is 550.
480 right and then other people you know
testosterone is 860 but they you look at
them and you think oh they kind of have
kind of a doughy look to them and so
it's got to be this free testosterone
thing plus estrogen et cetera so
training training and nutrition too
right i mean i just think i i think
for all this talk about testosterone
which i enjoy talking about and you know
i enjoy talking about the data on you
know long-term health consequences of
testosterone because it's another
controversial topic
um i also think people kind of overstate
its importance i agree um and i think
there's a there's a there's a group of
people who think if i could just fix my
testosterone everything will be better
and it's sort of like
no actually that's not true at all
really the only purpose in my mind of
fixing testosterone is to give you
the capacity to work harder
it's really going to help you recover
more from your workouts this should just
give you a greater ability to experience
muscle protein synthesis
so you know if i just give you a bunch
of testosterone and you sit on the couch
and your nutrition doesn't change and
you're not exercising anymore you're not
going to experience any benefits of this
thing i mean my testosterone level has
fluctuated quite a bit throughout my
life and when i think about as an adult
not not sort of including when i was
sort of a fanatical teenager but as an
adult when was i at my absolute most
insane physique like my best
performance on a dexa scan would have
been
30 i was 38 years old
by dexa i was 7 body fat my fat free
mass index was like 23.2
23.3
kilograms per meter squared
i mean i was
huge strong and totally ripped
my testosterone was in the toilet i was
over training like crazy
i was you know exercising probably 26
hours a week
killing it in the gym swimming like a
banshee cycling like my life depended on
it grossly over trained low t
but you know i mean physically looked
like twice the guy i am today you know
today my tea is probably twice as high
as it was then
so
you know no you could say well peter
what if you took tea back then how much
better could you have been sure um but
again i think the take home is
just giving somebody tea doesn't do much
of anything it probably helps on the
insulin resistance front without any
other thing
but to me that's a waste like that's
squandering the gift that it is giving
you which is the ability to do more work
and
you know capture the benefit of it via
muscle protein synthesis i agree and i
think that the psychological effect of
testosterone whether or not it's
exogenous or endogenous is it makes
effort feel good yeah at some level it
really seems to do that and sapolsky
tells me the main reason
or mechanistically the main reason that
it can do that is by adjusting levels of
activity in the amygdala
and so there's some interesting imaging
there
i'd love to chat more about the
cholesterol pathway and i know this is a
huge landscape as well but i think we're
doing a good job of diving in deep but
not getting stuck in the underlying
currents at all
there's tremendous debate about
whether or not dietary cholesterol
directly relates to or does not relate
to serum cholesterol ldl and hdl here's
my answer
i think well let me put it this way
there are people that argue i'm
certainly not arguing yeah there are
people that argue
that
if one eats a ton of saturated fat
that
ldl goes up and
but that's not dietary cholesterol per
se no not dietary cholesterol per se but
and then there are people that argue
that um
you know
any increase in saturated fat intake is
going to be bad that you already
synthesize enough cholesterol for
hormone production etc
i'd like to talk about this in terms of
how one should read their charts
my ldl is in what i'm told is healthy
range my hdl is in what i know is
healthy range i do try and not overeat
things like butter cheese and red meat
but i do eat some of those things and i
feel pretty good but
most people are
operating under the assumption that
eating saturated fat is bad and you only
do it insofar as you want to taste it
and then of course there's a small group
of people that
love to eat organs and meats and and
really pack cholesterol
and would argue that doesn't matter if
your ldl is 870
it's not going to impact your health
what's the reality around ldl uh hdl
dietary cholesterol saturated fat uh at
least in your view
uh so first let's differentiate between
cholesterol and fat just for the
listener
because we use them so you know i don't
want to make sure people understand so
so cholesterol is a is a really
complicated molecule so it's a ringed
molecule
um got i used to know exactly what its
structure was but like it could have 36
carbons for all i remember
it is a lipid so it is a hydrophobic
molecule that is synthesized by every
cell in the human body
it is so important that without it
if you look at sort of genetic uh
conditions that impair cholesterol
synthesis
depending on their severity they can be
fatal in utero
so in other words anything that really
interferes with our ability to produce
cholesterol will is a threat to us as a
species
and the reason for that is cholesterol
makes up
the cell membrane of every cell in our
body so you know as you know but maybe
the listeners don't
even though a cell is a spherical thing
it has to be fluid right it's not just a
rigid like sphere
like a you know blow up ball right it's
got to be able to kind of move
in this way
to mesh with other cells it also has to
accommodate having porous structures
that traverse its membrane to allow ions
and things like that to go across
and it's cholesterol that gives the
fluidity to that membrane it's also as
you're alluding to the backbone of some
of the most important hormones in our
body estrogen
progesterone testosterone
cortisol
um so we have this thing super important
okay
then let's talk about does cholesterol
can you get cholesterol in your diet
yes you can eat foods that are rich in
cholesterol
what was known
in 1960 but somehow escaped everybody's
imagination until finally the american
heart association acknowledged this a
few years ago is that the cholesterol
you eat
does not really make it into your body
and the reason for that is it's
hysterified
so we have and not to get too nerdy but
i think people i think if i really think
it's important people understand how
this thing works so we have cells in our
gut and enterocytes that they're the
endothelial cells of our gut
they have each one of them has basically
two transporters on them so the first is
called the niemann pick c1 like one
transporter the second is called the atp
binding cassette g5 g8
okay the neiman pixe one like one
transporter will bring in any sterol
cholesterol zeus sterol phytosterol any
sterol that fits through the door will
come in
virtually all of that is the cholesterol
we produce
that gets taken back to the liver that
the liver packages in bile and secretes
so that's that's what aids in our
digestion which is another thing i
should have mentioned earlier in
addition to using cholesterol for cell
membranes and hormones we wouldn't be
able to digest our food without
cholesterol because it's what makes up
the bile salts
so
our own cholesterol is basically
recirculated in a pool throughout our
body and this is the way it gets back
into the body it's through this neman
pixy one like one transporter when it
gets in there the body this is the
checkpoint of regulation this is where
the body says do you have enough
cholesterol in the body yes or no if yes
i will let that cholesterol make its way
into the circulation so it'll go off the
basolateral side of the cell not the
luminal side into the body alternatively
the body says you know what we have
enough cholesterol i'm going to let you
poop this out and now the atp binding
cassette will shoot it out it'll go back
into the luminal side and away it goes
the so all of the cholesterol in our
body is not esterified and it doesn't
have that big bulky side chain attached
to it
the cholesterol you eat is esterified
and an esterified cholesterol molecule
simply can't physically pass through
that neiman pixie one like one
transporter now
we probably manage to de-esterify
10 to 15 percent of our dietary
cholesterol so in other words there are
small amounts of dietary cholesterol
that do make their way into our
circulation
but it represents a small fraction of
our total body's pool of cholesterol
again this was known even by ansel keyes
the the guy who turned fat into the
biggest boogeyman of all time ansel keys
acknowledged this in the 1960s
dietary cholesterol plays no role in
serum cholesterol
uh again it took the american heart
association another 60 years to figure
that out but even now they acknowledge
that dietary cholesterol has no bearing
so why is it that it's pretty easy to
find
studies or at least people
with who are highly credentialed from
good institutions claiming that eating
saturated fat
that's different
saturated fat and red meat things that
are rich in cholesterol
to be more specific
is bad for us in terms of our eventual
ldl so this is two different things so
saturated fat consumption in many people
will raise ldl cholesterol
so it's important to differentiate
between the what what is saturated fat
so saturated fat of course is a fatty
acid just so people understand totally
different molecule from cholesterol
cholesterol is very complicated ring
structure multiple rings stuck together
sfa saturated fat is just a long chain
fatty acid that is fully saturated
meaning it has no double bonds and it
can exist in isolation it can exist in a
triglyceride triacylglyceride
or a you know a phospholipid or all
sorts of things like that
so when we eat foods that contain fat
basically there are three distinctions
for that fat is it saturated is it
monounsaturated one double bond or is it
polyunsaturated two or more double bonds
the observation that eating saturated
fat
raises cholesterol
is generally correct
but again now it makes because if we're
going to start talking about ldl we have
to explain what ldl is this is another
one of those things that's just so
grossly misunderstood that it's uh
it makes having
discussions about this very complicated
um let's go back to the cholesterol
problem right so every cell in our body
makes cholesterol
and almost without exception they make
enough
there are a handful of times however
when a cell needs to borrow cholesterol
from another cell
okay so how would you do this right so
if you're if you're sort of if you're
playing god for a minute and you want to
design a system you have to be able to
transport cholesterol from one cell to
another
the most logical place you would
transport this is through the
circulation
and the problem with circulation is it's
water plasma is water
so now you have this problem which is i
want to transport cargo that is
hydrophobic
in a hydrophilic medium can't do it
so if you think about all the things
that we transport in our blood sodium
electrolytes you know glucose things
like that
they're water-soluble it's easy they
just move back and forth in our blood
with no chaperone but when you want to
move cholesterol you have to package it
in something that's hydrophilic
that something is called a lipoprotein
so they have these we have these
spherical molecules that are lipid on
the inside protein on the outside
lipoprotein
and inside they contain cholesterol and
triglycerides
so now you've got the spherical thing
triglyceride cholesterol on the inside
and it's chaperoned by a hydrophilic
molecule that allows it to move through
our circulation
and those lipoproteins exist in
different densities so if you run these
out on a gel electrophoresis plate
you'll you'll identify different
densities the density is a function of
how much protein and how much lipid is
in it
so the highest density of this is called
a high density lipoprotein and the
lowest density of this is called a very
low density lipoprotein a vldl
and then next to that you have an ldl a
low density lipoprotein and then next to
that you have an idl an intermediate
density lipoprotein
so um
you know it actually goes vldl i dll
deal but anyway so um
when people say my ldl is high or my ldl
is 100 what are they saying
they're saying the cholesterol
concentration of my ldl particles is 100
milligrams per deciliter
so the total cholesterol concentration
you have in your circulation
is that number that says total
cholesterol so if someone's blood panel
says my total cholesterol is 200
it means that if you take all the
lipoproteins in their circulation bust
them open and measure the cholesterol
content it's 200 milligrams per
deciliter and for all intents and
purposes because the idls are so
short-lived that's basically the sum of
your ldl cholesterol your vldl
cholesterol and your hdl cholesterol
those three things sum to your total
cholesterol what about ldl little a that
you mentioned earlier lp little lasers
yeah he's another actor he is a special
type of ldl that again in sort of 10 to
20 of the population
is a really bad actor so that's an ldl
that has another april lipoprotein on it
called apolipoprotein little a got it
the other thing i'll just say on this
because earlier i mentioned apob
there are two broad families of
lipoproteins there are those that are
wrapped in apob's and those that are
wrapped in apoas the apoa family is the
hdl family the apo b family is the vldl
idl ldl family i see so for somebody who
let's say their total cholesterol is
let's just stay with 200 for simplicity
uh what do you like to see in terms of
the hdl ldl ratio couldn't care less
i only care about apob
i only care about apob
i care about the causative agent of
atherosclerosis
apob is the thing that drives
atherosclerosis
and what levels are attractive or
repulsive for you when you see uh levels
of apob that are blank you get really
concerned um what depends on the
person's objectives
so again we take a very different view
i mean we have
vitality now live to and i want to live
to be a hundred yeah so if you're
assuming some tape if you tell me you
want to live to be a hundred you're
going to need to keep your apo b below
30 milligrams per deciliter let's say i
want to live to be a hundred but i also
well how about i i don't care how long i
live but i want to feel great while i
live
again it depends right like anybody
who's had a heart attack is going to be
compromised in their ability to feel
well after
right so i guess i point i make say it
that way because if you're going to tell
me that
in order to achieve that live to 100
level i'm going to have to uh give up my
personal life and my uh no no
my brain functioning then then i'm not
really interested in sure but but to get
ldl levels
and really again people think of it as
ldl it's really apob right apob is this
total concentration of ldl and vldl and
that's what matters those are the big
atherogenic particles ldl also includes
the the lp little a although the
concentration of lp little a is
relatively speaking so small that it
doesn't generally show up as much in the
apob so we treat apob and basically what
it comes down to is you want apob to be
as close to the level as it was when you
were born so we start developing heart
disease when we're born
that's just the way it is
the autopsy studies make this abundantly
clear when you look at autopsies of
young people who are dying in their 20s
and this was first done in the 1970s it
was again repeated again it's always
done after we have a war right so in the
1970s it was done on people you know who
died in vietnam in the early 2000s it
was done on mostly young men but some
young women who were you know dying in
iraq and afghanistan and we saw without
any ambiguity that cardiovascular
disease is already taking hold in people
who are 18 19 20 years old wow and to be
clear they aren't going to die of
atherosclerosis at that age they're
still 40 50 years away from it but this
is a lifelong disease
and we also know that the disease can't
really develop until apob reaches a
certain threshold
and that's the threshold that most of us
get to by the time we're you know sort
of in our teens
so it's this really young apob level of
kind of 20 to 30 milligrams per
deciliter that makes it impossible to
get atherosclerosis so apob is necessary
but not sufficient to develop ascvd
now that go ahead oh i'm sorry i was
just going to ask what are some of the
top behavioral nutritional
supplementation if any based and
prescription drug based ways to target
apob
well nutritionally you basically have
two big tools right and it depends on
what's driving up apob so apob remember
is the concentration of ldl and vldl
particles and what do they carry
cholesterol and triglycerides so
anything that reduces cholesterol and
reduces triglycerides is going to reduce
apob
triglycerides are generally driven by
carbohydrate intake
so more insulin resistance more
carbohydrate intake more triglycerides
so
we
i mean clinically this is readily
apparent to anyone who treats patients
if you restrict carbohydrates you will
reduce triglycerides that just happens
all day long but if you reduce
triglycerides by raising fat intake so
much it can still raise apob
so so you have to be able to think about
it so so in an ideal world it's can you
lower
saturated fat which tends to be the one
that is most driving apob while lowering
carbohydrate and then see what you can
get but here's the reality of it is
there's nobody with dietary intervention
that's going to get to a level of 30
milligrams per deciliter i mean i've
never seen any pure dietary intervention
yeah so what are the other things it's
going to be pharmacologic at this point
statin type integration well now you
have multiple classes of drugs so the
tried and true is the statin so statins
work by inhibiting cholesterol synthesis
and the
net effect of that is that the so the
liver is really sensitive to cholesterol
levels it doesn't want too much it
doesn't want too little when you inhibit
cholesterol synthesis the liver says i
want more cholesterol
so it puts more ldl receptors on its
surface and it pulls the ldl out of
circulation
that's what lowers the ldl in the
circulation
um
so
again nine statins in use today we
typically use four of them um the side
effect profile contrary to kind of all
the sort of statin-hating propaganda out
there very benign right five percent of
people experience muscle soreness which
reverses upon cessation um
you know
cognitive effects
again i think it's v in terms of actual
comparing it in a placebo no effect
whatsoever right so does that mean that
you put a patient on it they won't
complain of something no but if you look
at clinical trials there's no evidence
whatsoever that statins impair cognition
there's also no evidence in clinical
trials that they accelerate the risk of
neurodegenerative disease in fact it's
the opposite now we will there's a
there's a very nuanced case we make
andrew which is we'll look at patients
with highly suppressed desmosterol
levels
we will back off we we do want to
maintain desmosterol above a certain
level um because of some
evidence that is still i think very
preliminary but enough for us that we
say why take the chance we have so many
other tools to lower cholesterol why
would we over suppress synthesis in a
susceptible individual
um
so the next tool you look at is a drug
that blocks the absorption or the
reabsorption of cholesterol that
remember that neiman pixie one like one
transporter so that guy
has um a drug called ezetimibe that just
mechanically blocks it so
in people and that's why i mentioned
earlier we men we measure all those
sterols in people so we also measure
things called phytosterols and the
phytosterols give us an indication of
how active that transporter is so the
higher your phytosterols the more likely
you are to respond to zetamod
next class of drugs
is a drug that blocks cholesterol
synthesis but only in the liver so the
statin does it globally
the this other drug called bendoic acid
does it only in the liver so it has a
very similar mechanism to statins
different enzyme
not quite as potent but way fewer side
effects so any patient that's having a
response to statins that's adverse we'll
try this other thing
what's it called one more time
bempendilic acid then pedoic acid the
most potent drug of the lot is the pcsk9
inhibitor so pcsk9 is a protein that was
discovered in the late
90s i believe
is responsible for the degradation of
ldl receptors
this was first discovered in people who
had a condition called familial
hypercholesterolemia or fh so these are
people that have incredibly high
cholesterol typically their total
cholesterol level is 300 their ldl
cholesterol is typically you know north
of 200 milligrams per deciliter
this is a
disease that is defined by the phenotype
not the genotype so the phenotype has a
very clear definition which i basically
just gave you the genotype is there's a
million paths to get there
there's over three thousand mutations
that are known to produce that phenotype
this was discovered to be one of them in
people who had hyper functioning pci
pcsk bcsk9
this protein was just constantly
hammering and destroying the ldl
receptors and so their ldl would be huge
and by extension their total cholesterol
would be so
in 199 sorry in 2006 helen hobbs and
colleagues discovered an opposite group
of population people who had ldl
cholesterol naturally of 10 to 20
milligrams per deciliter which would be
an apob of about 20 milligrams per
deciliter
um
and who never got heart disease they
were immune to heart disease no matter
how long they live and they had the
opposite they had hypo functioning pcsk9
and so that was 2006 the new england
journal of medicine that basically got a
whole bunch of drug companies hot on the
trail of producing a drug to mimic it so
now we have these antibodies and they're
wildly effective what percentage of your
patients over
45
uh do you have on either a statin or on
one of these other well often it's in
combinations and i would say eighty
percent
eight zero we have to remember what our
objective is like we're in the business
of trying to make sure people live as
long as possible and you have to take a
sort of world view of this right if you
like what's the most prevalent cause of
death globally it's like cardiovascular
yeah and like how close is it so
the the last year before covid kova kind
of messes up these numbers a little bit
but if you go to 2019
18.6 million people died of heart
disease
number two cancer 10 million like
like nothing's in the zip code of
atherosclerosis
and if you remember what i just said if
you if you had if you took everybody in
their 20s and reduced them
to a level of that of a child you'd make
ascvd an orphan disease
so
so the question why don't we hear more
why don't we hear more about this i
realize there's some nuance it's it's
it's not straightforward it's not as
simple as saying eat less cheese red
meat and and watch your ldl
get on a statin but why do we hear so
little about apob in the general
discussion social media is such a skewed
landscape
as we know um people shouting into
tunnels of
uh
varying uh clarity you know some are
beautiful
bronze tunnels with clean walls and
others are sewer lines right
um and they all converge in the same
place right as we know um but why do we
hear so little about this i mean i'm not
on a statin um but now i'm beginning to
think that maybe that might be a good
idea to consider one of these other
compounds i don't know the last time i
looked at my apob specifically i'm
guessing my physician did but um
why don't we hear more about this this
is it sounds so important it sounds like
the most important conversation because
all the hormone stuff and all the stuff
about
um
smoking and head injuries and adhd and
all the rest i mean is irrelevant if
you're dead right yeah um that's a great
question i don't think i have a great
insight as to why this isn't more front
and center um
i think the bigger
problem is why don't we even understand
how to think about it i mean the the the
and there's a whole chapter in my book
i'm working on that really gets to this
problem of why why aren't we looking at
atherosclerosis
in terms of treating the causative agent
instead we look at
modifying 10-year risk so that's the
fundamental difference between what i
call medicine 2.0 and medicine 3.0
medicine 2.0 which is what we're
generally practicing today when it comes
to ascbd says look we will treat you we
will lower that ldl cholesterol they
still don't talk about apob but that's a
very american thing if you go outside of
the united states everybody's talking
about apob it's in the guidelines in
europe and canada everywhere else the
united states is very stubborn on this
and it's due to a couple of really weird
personalities in the lipid world um but
um
but the the paradigm is
when your 10-year risk
reaches 5 when there's a 5 chance that
you're going to have a heart attack
stroke or die in the next 10 years now
it's time to treat you
medicine 3.0 says that's not the way to
think about it you treat the causative
agent
if there's a causative agent you treat
it if blood pressure raises the risk of
heart disease you lower blood pressure
if smoking raises the risk of something
you treat smoking
and the reason that the risk model is so
bad when you're looking at 10-year risk
is age is the biggest driver of risk
i mean bar none right so if you take a
70 year old with perfect lipids
and perfect blood pressure and perfect
everything their 10-year risk of ascbd
is probably four to five times higher
than the most unhealthy 30 year old it's
not even close yeah there's a lot like
eye disease you know you there are
exceptions of course we always say that
the biggest risk factor for going blind
from glaucoma is being an older person
you know right so if you could identify
what the risk factors are for glaucoma
imagine if the paradigm was
we're only going to treat it when your
risk of blindness reaches five percent
which isn't triggered until you're old
enough anyway wouldn't you rather know
that when you're 30 and say wait if
maybe being in the sun without
sunglasses or you know using this type
of eye drop or something like that has a
negative impact i'd rather know that
sooner so
that's the fundamental difference it's a
philosophical difference with respect to
prevention and i will acknowledge that
in one element of prevention i make no
consideration i am only coming at this
through the lens of the individual i am
never coming at this through the lens of
society that makes my life
easier and it makes the problem i'm
solving easier i don't have to answer
the quality adjusted life year problem i
don't have to ask the question is it
economical to treat people at 30.
i don't know the answer that question
but i also know that when you're trying
to solve really complicated problems the
more you can simplify the better so i've
just acknowledged openly not solving
that if you want to criticize me for it
that's fine let's be transparent but all
i care about is the person i'm sitting
across from and in that situation
it's really their decision if they can
justify the cost of treatment
an esoteric question and then a less
esoteric question the esoteric question
relates to something that i think is a
little bit niche but
not
necessarily so which is um peptides and
stem cells in prp i don't want to go off
on too much of a tangent on rehab but i
know you've done a number of posts on
social media recently that were i have
to tell you a really thoughtful and i
really appreciate that you're willing to
share your own
tissue rehabilitation experience and
point people that because
this is a landscape that a lot of people
are in and they don't know how to
navigate it and a mutual friend of ours
not to be named send me a text and said
i'm going to be talking to a tia and
what do you know about studies on things
like bpc157 this gastric peptide that
anecdotally again anecdotally people
report getting injections of this into
shoulder knee etc and feeling so much
better so much faster but there really
aren't good studies controlled studies
and
you hear all the same sorts of things
about
platelet-rich plasma prp which if
someone tells you there are a lot of
stem cells in them they're lying they're
not a lot of stem cells in them and you
also hear about stem cells which are not
fda approved at least in this you know
for most uses in this country but are
certainly people are flying down to
colombia and getting injections and
what is your understanding or experience
with things like bpc157 specifically
because peptides is a huge landscape we
should probably do a whole episode of
peptides um things like prp um prp is
now approved for i mean women are
getting injections of this into their
ovaries to improve uh follicle count we
know this um people are getting
injections of prp into every tissue and
organ in it hell men are getting
injected in their penis so i hear um for
all sorts of reasons that are unclear to
me
um what's the deal with prp bpc157 and
stem cells do you ever see interesting
effects are you curious about these um
compounds do you prescribe or direct
people towards these the fda approved
ones of course yeah so short answer is
i'm definitely curious about them and
i'd love to see the work done but i also
think this is about as wild wild west as
it gets uh prp less so uh but certainly
stem cells and peptides
and
you know i just think
if you're going to do something without
a clinical trial you got to show up with
a lot more data right so let's use
rapamycin as an example right i'm a huge
proponent of rapamycin and you can say
well peter how can you take or prescribe
rapamycin for geroprotective effects
when we do not have a human clinical
trial demonstrating that it lengthens
life
and the answer is because i have 84
other pieces of data that all point in
the same direction
across every model organism going back
more than a billion years
and that's really different from
joey sammy and sally did this thing and
i think it works
and they just can't be compared now i
have no idea if stem cells work i have
no idea if bpc157 works i have no idea
frankly if prp even works though it
might seem to have some efficacy and
some indications for example maybe when
it comes to early hair loss maybe when
it comes to you know certain joint
issues
but the reality of it is like i think we
just have to accept the fact that
everything we do has an opportunity cost
and that opportunity cost is sometimes
financial
but i actually find a lot of times it's
in time and effort and energy that goes
into something now when i was you know
waiting to get my shoulder surgery this
is an injury that i've had forever right
there's an injury
you know i've i this this injury was
actually probably the greatest source of
discomfort i had swimming the catalina
channel the last time in 2009 so that's
that tells you how long i've had this
injury
um but you know i sort of knew at some
point like i'm gonna have to have it
fixed
and i sort of went down this rabbit hole
like hey is there anything i can do to
avoid having surgery you know would
infusing a million stem cells into it
work um and in speaking with
as many orthopedic surgeons as i could
the answer was kind of unambiguously no
and by the way it doesn't mean you
wouldn't feel better if i injected a
bunch of stem cells into your shoulder
there are a lot of reasons that might
make you feel better just like there are
a bunch of reasons you can feel better
if somebody injects saline directly into
your joint
yeah so so the the question is is it
going to fix the underlying problem and
if so will it do so by what mechanism
so i'm pretty sure that if you took a
thousand people with my particular
injury and injected them with stem cells
it wouldn't do a thing because of the
nature of my injury i had a complete
labral tear
um
are there some injuries that might
benefit from it yeah possible so the
question is how would you design the
trial to narrow down your patient
population
correctly so that you might see a signal
because the other risk of doing a trial
is
you have too much of a heterogeneous
patient population
it's you don't know what the heck you're
really doing and you get meaningless
results you get a null result when in
fact there's a small signal but you were
underpowered to pick it up because you
know you only had 10 percent of your
patient population that was the right
patient population to get that so
you know will we ever get there i don't
know because i don't see what the
incentive is right you have people who
are making money hand over fist doing
procedures
on the basis of i'm not sure what what
would their motivation or incentive be
to to sort of see this legitimized uh
you'd really have to be able to say well
there really needs to be sort of a
pharma angle to this
um
it's sort of one of the wishes i had
right like if i was if i was a
billionaire i feel like the way i would
probably waste all of my money would be
running clinical trials on stuff nobody
cared about yeah it might just likewise
i would join you because that would be
yesterday we recorded a sit down with
somebody from caltech who works on uh
aggression
and rage and thing and other things
related to that and has identified
peptides that are approved the fda for
other reasons that seem to adjust
anxiety might even adjust aggression and
pathologic aggression and went off on to
a long description of why none of these
drugs exist on the market for the
treatment of psychiatric illness and yet
probably would work
um
and what's missing is a
billionaire or a billion dollar company
that is willing to invest in something
that very likely will work but the
market value isn't quite there or it
failed in a previous trial and so no one
wants to touch it with a 10 foot pole
hopefully someone listening to this will
be incentivized to provide this sort of
a venue for that uh the kind of work
that we're talking about
i have to ask but but i want to make one
other point andrew which is
to me the problem
with a lot of these things is it gets
it's a crutch
you know it's sort of like what we
talked about with like hey just fix my
tea man and everything's going to be
fine and it's like no that's just the
beginning you know what i worry about
when i see people who are clamoring for
this stuff is a lot of times they don't
realize that whether it's
psychologically or otherwise they sort
of say well now that i've had this thing
done i don't have to do the hard work of
the real rehab i mean if i've learned
anything through my shoulder surgery and
i'm now three and a half months out how
does it feel amazing i mean look i still
can't do a lot of stuff it's going to be
you know a while i haven't even been
able to shoot a bow yet and it'll
probably be
a year before i'll go back to you know
long dead hangs and heavy deadlifts i
mean i don't know maybe nine months but
it's you know i'm not there yet
but what i learned through a really
amazing prehab and rehab process is
like you just gotta do the work and it's
freaking hard shoulders are the most
tedious boring thing in the world i mean
three days a week i am doing for four
days a week i am doing one hour of just
dedicated
stuff for this shoulder that is
super disk super uncomfortable
super boring
super frustrating um
but i i mean i have faith in the
methodology right and and i think a lot
of people are saying just shoot the stem
cells into me i don't have to do any of
that stuff and the reality of it is i i
think that's a very dangerous place to
be
have you ever tried bpc157
um yeah we tried it um we had you know
again maybe
seven eight years ago we had a bunch of
patients ask about it so
you know my view is okay i was pretty
convinced that there was no safety
downside to it so i was like well i
wouldn't prescribe it to a patient
unless i tried it myself so me and
another doc in the practice ralph we did
it for i don't know a couple months i
didn't notice a single thing
interesting
well thank you for that um shifting to a
less esoteric but
uh and i think probably more important
topic overall
metabolomics talking about this before
we sat down to record
what what is what are metabolomics
why should we be thinking about them uh
i have some idea of what it might be
about uh but
most people i think are not thinking
about metabolomics
at all and for those that are i'm sure
they could learn more so tell us about
metabolomics and what you'd like to see
more of in the world of metabolomics
yeah so omics is just the term that we
use to describe the study of of
something so genome makes right is like
the broad study of genes and uh you know
proteomics the broad study of proteins
and things like that so so metabolomix
is the study of metabolites and
metabolites unlike a lot of these other
things they're a relatively finite
number of these things many of which are
known but some of which are not known so
glucose is a metabolite acetyl coa is a
metabolite lactate is a metabolite and
so the question is what do we know about
these things and how they work and more
importantly what do we know about
certain physiologic states and the
metabolomic profile that results from
them so
let's use two extreme examples like
exercise
everybody understands the data are
unambiguously clear exercise produces
about the most favorable phenotype
imaginable
so
if you wanted to take a genomics
approach to understanding that you might
look at is there a change in the genome
when you exercise and the answer is
probably not but maybe maybe if you
looked at the you know methylation
patterns and epigenome you could look at
epigenomic studies
um but you might instead look at kind of
the proteomic side of that like what is
gene expression doing
and there you would see a lot of changes
well what i don't think people are
really understanding although there was
a very interesting paper that just came
out um
two weeks ago
that looks for novel metabolites that
are changing is there a huge signal in a
metabolomic profile that looks different
in the state of exercise versus
non-exercise and could that represent
part of how exercise is transmitting its
benefit through the body
um you know people always talk about the
holy grail of metabolomics would be can
you find pill to mimic exercise
and i think the answer that question is
going to be undoubtedly no know
for a couple reasons one even if you
could mimic the longevity sort of
lifespan parts of it you could never
mimic the health span parts of it
but what if you could do both right what
if there were small molecules that can
replicate some of the protective
benefits of exercise and you could
combine those with exercise what if
those could be treatments for other
disease states like diabetes things like
that so that's why i think this field of
metabolomics is you know relatively
untapped
and and i think you know potentially the
next sort of frontier
speaking of frontiers i hear a lot
nowadays about glp-1 and
[Music]
pharmacology that prescription drugs
that mimic or increase glp1 directly
glucagon like peptide
people are talking about this as the
blockbuster obesity drug i haven't heard
this much talk about a drug to adjust
human body weight
favorably since the discussions of
fenfen when i was in college and then of
course fen pen was pulled from the
market um because people were dying
uh not left and right but enough people
died that they pulled it from the market
which by the way is an interesting uh
story you know it was the enantimer that
they chose to use that was the wrong
enantiomer and what it resulted in was
um god i think it was like
some mitral valve overlaps was it was it
mvp yeah it was something in the mitral
valve um yeah i think the chordae
tendineae were rupturing and the mitral
valve um and and it was mostly young
women i think we're getting you know
horrible pulmonary disease as a result
of it probably pulmonary hypertension or
something like that
um
but there were you know there were two
enantiomers of the drug and had they
just used the other one this issue
wouldn't have happened and there was a
stupid reason why they made the choice
to use the one they did and it's one of
those things where once you make the
mistake you're never going back it's not
like that company could say okay we want
to do over but we're going to do it with
the right version so
it's a tragic outcome uh but but you're
absolutely right i think the glp-1
agonists are have more efficacy
um and you know uh for all intensity and
for everything we can see certainly
seems safer are you excited about them
yeah i am yeah i mean i think i think
we're just seeing the kind of tip of the
iceberg they're not they're not miracle
drugs right they come with problems
right which is you know they're they're
they're catabolic across the board so
patients are losing fat but they're
losing muscle as well
so
you just sent all the the uh jim jockeys
running from semi-glutathione
that's all you have to say all you have
to say nowadays about something is that
it's going to drop testosterone lower
fertility change someone's skin hair or
nails and it's like people
it could extend life to being 250 years
old and people are gone
humans are human that's a that's a
neuroscience and psychology issue not a
not a biology medicine issue um but i'm
i'm pleased to hear that you're excited
by them because i hear a lot of
excitement yeah i haven't heard anything
disastrous about them it takes a while
to get people up to dose so if you're
looking at semi-glutide the dose that
was studied um so they did a one-year
trial or maybe it was a little over that
maybe 60 weeks but it took about 16
weeks to get the patients
comfortably up to 2.4 milligrams weekly
which was the dose that they ultimately
stayed on in our experience when we use
it we don't even usually go up to 2.4
milligrams we can usually get enough
benefit between one and two milligrams
and we usually move people along a
little bit quicker but we've definitely
had our share of patients who can't
tolerate it due to the nausea
interesting which might be part of how
it's working right is the sort of
suppression of appetite which if taken
to an extreme can produce nausea
interesting yeah i think most of the
effective of semiglutid is central not
peripheral huh so i don't know i saw one
paper
that
glp-1 is acting both on cells in in the
periphery um to cause gut distension in
some ways or sort of make people feel
full through promotion of
literally mechanoreceptors that make
people feel as if their stomach is
distended even though their stomach is
empty and then perhaps some essential
hypothalamic effects is that yeah i
think it's doing
i would bet 80 percent of it's in the
hypothalamus um it is also improving
insulin sensitivity in the periphery but
i don't think that that's accounting for
much of its benefit
super interesting and there's next-gen
um versions of these that seem to be
more long-lasting so right now if you
look at
coming off semi-glue tide going to see a
weight regain so there's newer versions
that seem to preserve the weight loss
even off the drug
so it begs the ultimate question which
is like what's the what's the total use
case for this going to be is this going
to be a drug you cycle on and off or is
it going to be a drug that a person has
to stay on indefinitely and if so will
they become tachyphylactic will they
gain you know a resistance to it so it's
still super early days on these things
my hope is that it would be a little bit
like the way that you described
testosterone and estrogen therapies that
it would allow people to do more of the
behavioral work that's absolutely
required for health span and lifespan
yep and we've also seen on the flip side
of that you can
cheat through
semiglue type right people who you know
you can drink a lot of calories and sort
of
get around the drug
so you know for example like you know
we we always encourage patients who want
to lose weight to really just eliminate
alcohol like that's like that's the
cheapest easiest
trick to lose weight and so if you're
still drinking a lot of alcohol which is
incredibly caloric and just drinking a
lot of caloric stuff um we've seen that
that's less this is just anecdotal in
our with our patients but we've seen
that that's
it's easier to get around the benefits
of the drug that way interesting
i so appreciate your answers today first
of all they were incredibly thorough um
and pointed towards real world
application
i also just want to thank you
more broadly for the work that you do
because obviously you have this
incredible clinical experience and
patient population that you work very
closely with but i see you really as one
of the few
both
clinicians and i realize you're an md i
did you do a phd as well no but i
consider you a scientist clinician a
clinician scientist is the appropriate
wording of that of course in the way
that you really still drill into studies
in detail i know a lot of clinicians not
all of them do that
for sure
and the fact that you're so hungry for
the new incoming knowledge as well as
the the old literature so uh it's an
incredibly rich data set in that brain
of yours and i really appreciate you
sharing it with us both in your podcast
in the upcoming book which i think
we'll certainly have you on here again
um in anticipation of that but i know i
and a ton of other people are really
excited for the book and in the way that
you approach social media and your
podcast and going on podcasts so thank
you so much i learned a ton i know
everyone learned a tan thanks andrew
great to be here man
thank you thank you for joining me today
for my discussion with dr peter etia all
about the things that we can do in order
to maximize our lifespan and health span
i highly recommend people check out dr
atiya's podcast the drive is excellent
as you can imagine based on today's
conversation and it's easily available
on apple podcast spotify overcast and
google please also check out dr otia's
website it's peteratiamd.com
there you can find links to his podcast
episodes as well as a sign up for his
excellent weekly newsletter that
newsletter provides terrific information
related to health that anyone can
benefit from if you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a simple zero-cost way to support us
please also subscribe to the podcast on
spotify and apple and on both spotify
and apple you have the opportunity to
leave us up to a five-star review
if you have questions or comments or
suggestions about topics you'd like us
to cover or guess you'd like us to
interview on the hubermann lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on youtube we do read all those comments
and we do take them to heart please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning of today's podcast and check
out momentous supplements our new
partners in the supplement space and
check out athletic greens that's the
best way to support this podcast if
you're not already following us on
social media please do so we are
huberman lab on twitter and we are also
huberman lab on instagram and both
places i cover science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the huberman lab podcast
but much of which is unique from the
content covered on the huberman lab
podcast again that's huberman lab on
instagram and huberman lab on twitter
please also check out our neural network
monthly newsletter this is a newsletter
that has summaries of podcast episodes
it also includes a lot of actionable
protocols it's very easy to sign up for
the newsletter you go to hubermanlab.com
click on the menu go to newsletter you
supply your email but we do not share
your email with anybody we have a very
clear and rigorous privacy policy which
is we do not share your email with
anybody and the newsletter comes out
once a month and it is completely zero
cost again just go to hubermanlab.com
and go to the neural network newsletter
i'd also like to point out that the
huberman lab podcast has a clips channel
so these are brief clips anywhere from
three to ten minutes that encompass
single concepts and actionable protocols
related to sleep to focus
interviews with various guests we talk
about things like caffeine when to drink
caffeine relative to sleep
alcohol when and how and if anyone
should ingest it relative to sleep
dopamine serotonin mental health
physical health and on and on all the
things that relate to the topics most of
interest to you you can find that easily
by going to youtube look for huberman
lab clips in the search area it will
take you there subscribe and we are
constantly updating those with new clips
this is especially useful i believe for
people that have missed some of the
earlier episodes or you're still working
through the back catalog of hubrim and
lab podcast which admittedly can be
rather long and last but certainly not
least thank you for your interest in
science
[Music]